thank you
R has become the language for
statistical Computing and Graphics it is
one of the most popular analytic tools
our programming was written by Robert
gentleman and Ross e Haka at the
Auckland University New Zealand R is a
free and open source software that is
commonly used to solve statistics time
series classification clustering and
other data science tasks it is also
widely preferred for data visualization
because it has a collection of great
packages the availability of our
packages makes it stand differently from
the other programming languages
by learning R you can become a data
scientist statistician data analyst art
programmer or a business analyst with
sectors such as Healthcare e-commerce
retail Banking and finance with more and
more companies focusing on generating
insights from data a significant growth
has been noticed in our programming over
the years some of the top companies
using are include Google Amazon Twitter
IBM Oracle and Firefox
so R is constantly evolving and keeping
itself ahead of the edge ours vast
Community ensures that R does not get
outdated or old school as they keep
adding new functionalities and updates
with that let's have a look at the
agenda for our R programming course for
2022. first we will look into variables
and data types then we will move on to
logical operators following which we
will look into Vector Matrix list and
data frames then we will look into
functions and flow control statements
followed by D plier and tidier for data
manipulation next we will look into
ggplot library for data visualization
and finally have a look at time series
in R so let's get started
let's see what is our programming
and how it helps so R is well known as a
language of data science now if you
really look at the ranking from survey
of data mining experts based on the
softwares they have often used in their
work R is used more than python when it
comes to data science python is also
used however R is predominantly more
used for data science kind of activities
it's a open source programming language
used for statistical Computing it is one
of the most popular programming
languages today it was inspired by S
Plus and it is similar to S programming
language so when it comes to data
science
what we can say is R is a popularly used
programming language across the globe it
is free and open source as I mentioned
it is optimized for Vector operations
which we will learn about later
it has an amazing Community has in fact
9000 plus contributed or Community
packages allowing us to do almost
anything or everything using r
now when we talk about features of our
as I said it's open source programming
language so you can install R for free
and you can straight away start working
you wouldn't have to really go for a
licensed version or pay for the software
non-coders can also understand and
perform programming in r as it is easy
to understand and it has various data
structures and operators it can be
integrated with other programming
languages like C C plus plus Java and
python it consists of various inbuilt
packages a lot of sample data sets which
can be used and that makes reporting the
results of an analysis Easier by using R
now before we start learning about
variables Loops how you work with r and
so on it would be good to know how you
can set up R and work on R so for that
what you can do is you can just go to R
minus project
dot org
and
once we get to the home page of our
project for statistical computing using
this link we can click on download R
here
now that brings you to a page to
download it now there are various links
here so it shows you the comprehensive R
archive Network that is cran mirrors and
it is available at different URLs
however I would choose the first one
which is zero Cloud you can just click
on this one and then based on your
operating system whether you are working
on a Linux machine on a MacBook or
Windows you can install it so you can
just click on this one as of now I'm
using a Windows machine so I can click
on download R for Windows and that takes
me to this link which says binaries for
base distribution now this is what we
can use to work with r straight away
however there is one more package that
is our studio we will see how we can set
up that now this one takes us to the
best mirror possible
for our location from where we can
download r
so you can click on this base and then
you can download by clicking on this
link I have already downloaded this so
once you click on this one you can just
save it so I have it here already in my
downloads and that's more than enough
then you can just double click and you
can go through the instructions
to set up r that would also allow you to
basically set up a desktop shortcut
which I have already done here on my
machine and if I go in here I see our
base you can click on this one and that
brings you to the page which you can use
to straight away start working with r
now yes there is one more package called
rstudio which is set up on top of Base R
which makes working with r easier now
here also you can start working so it
shows you our console and you can click
on file and if you have some scripts or
files already written in the format of R
you can use those so I can click on open
script and that takes me to a page where
I have some files which are already
existing I can just select this one and
click on open and that shows me some
options here so I have an editor which
shows me say if I want to get a library
to use built-in data sets I could
summarize the data I could do a cleanup
and we'll see all of this but I would
suggest using R Studio rather than just
using base R however installing base R
would be required and depending on your
machine configuration like mine is a
64-bit I have chosen 64-bit while I was
setting up base R now when it comes to
rstudio
it is basically a package which makes
working with are easier
so to install our studio what you can do
is you can go to the r Studio home page
or you can just go to Google and say
Type R Studio download
and then it takes you to this page you
can click on this which says download
rstudio you can choose your version you
can go for the free version that is our
studio desktop and you can click on this
download and then you can download
rstudio for Windows which I have already
done and then you have to run through
the steps so just click on this one and
I already have our studio here right now
I can just basically use that so for
example if I go to downloads and if I
look for rstudio if I do a double click
I can say yes
and then it takes me to the r Studio
setup just click on next and here you
can choose the location if you would
want to place it in a specific location
click on next and then it says select
the start menu folder so let our studio
be chosen here click on install and then
it will basically start installing this
in a particular location now in my case
it is already existing right so we can
even click on show details and see what
it is doing what packages or what
executables it is extracting now once
this is done then you will be able to
use our studio you can also add a
shortcut to your taskbar and you can
continue using it so I've already done
this this might take couple of seconds
just wait for this to complete and you
would have rstudio
which is an easier way of working with
RF so a lot of developers across the
globe would be using rstudio when they
are working with R to work on their data
science or programming requirements
now let's just wait it is almost done
and now I can click on finish
so so that part is done you can add it
as a shortcut so rstudio has consistent
commands it has unified interface it
makes easy to navigate and manage
through r
and it is set up on top of your our base
now if I click and open on this
so that's my R Studio which is coming up
now here you see console which will show
you the result where you can give your
commands so where we can get text output
now again I can choose a file so I can
just say open file and then I can go
into a particular location where I have
downloaded some data and then basically
I can choose say for example our studio
and that brings me here so now you have
your script which has some commands
right
on the left bottom you have console
where you can see the output on the
right side you also have environment now
that is to use or provide variables and
then we can also have plots which we can
see here now we can look at this as an
example so here I am loading the
built-in data sets so what I can just do
is I can place my cursor here and I can
just do a control enter and that
basically loads the built-in data sets
which we can see here that has been done
now there is an inbuilt iris data set
and we can just use head option to look
at the first six lines of Iris data set
so just place your cursor and do a
control enter and that shows you a
summary
basically the first six lines of this
data set what it contains we will look
into this data set later this is a
default data set which you can easily
find when you're working with r you can
also have your cursor place on summary
and then just do a control enter so that
basically shows you summary statistics
for Iris data you can do a plot and that
basically shows you the plot which you
can also maximize and look at it in full
screen you can just do a zoom if you are
interested in looking into this and we
will discuss how or what kind of
information we can infer from the plots
now when it comes to cleaning up you can
just do detach and then we can say
package data sets and here we had loaded
those data sets so we are just doing a
detach and we can say unload equals true
so I'll just do a control enter I can
also clear off the plots by doing this
for whatever plots we had and we can
either do a edit and then we can do a
clear console from here or the shortcut
is Ctrl R and you can clear off the
console so that's a simple way of
starting your working with r by
installing R Studio
so let's continue learning about working
with r
and basically the first thing which we
should learn here is about variables in
R so variables as in any programming
language is a way to store your data
value
factor of list values or a data set or
object in r it allows us to conveniently
reference the variable name
basically saving us from rewriting the
data value or object many times in our
program so when we talk about variables
in R they are mainly used to store data
with named locations that your programs
can manipulate
a variable can be a combination of
letters digits period and underscore
so you can have some valid variables as
total sum you can also have dot notation
so there are different naming or style
conventions in R and we can use dot to
separate names in description of a
variable we can also start a variable
with DOT we can include numbers in a
variable and remember R is case
sensitive so we have to whenever we
declare a variable we need to remember
what case was used as in in the name of
the variable and there can be other
conventions also such as using an
underscore or even using a case in
between the variables so variables can
only consist of letters numbers periods
underscores your dot followed by n
letter not a number and we can declare
our variables we can also look at the
type of the variables and the class to
which it belongs so there are some
invalid variables which we are seeing
here so that also needs to be remembered
so this is an example where you can use
an assignment operator which you see
here between X and 10 to assign a value
to a variable you could also do that by
doing a DOT Y and then assign a value
you could be doing that by using a z and
then having a computation done between X
and Y and finally you could do a print
so let's see some example here before we
move further and for that I can bring up
my R Studio here so as I said we can
basically have different
kind of variables or naming conventions
for example I could do something like
model one and then I can basically
assign this so this is just a variable
and I could be assigning anything to it
I could be assigning different data
types which are available here for
example I could do something like this
and I could do a control
enter so
that's my variable I can always do a
type
off and then basically I can check
what's the type of my variable so it
tells it's a character I can also do a
class
and then I can basically say show me the
class and that shows me it belongs to
the character class we'll learn about
data types later but we are using
assignment operator now if I say what is
model 1 it shows me the value but if I
would do something like this then it
says object model not found and why
because it is case sensitive the
variable which we had created was all in
lower case
and the one which we try to call was
starting with an uppercase so you could
have variables created in such way I
could also do something like hello
underscore string and this could be my
variable where we are using an
underscore and then we can just given
something here and that becomes my
variable which you can always call
and check what is the value of that you
could also be doing something like this
so you could be using
different cases and then I could say
something like this and that's also my
variable
and then I can basically look at the
value of this variable now if we try to
create a variable where we start the
variable name with the number what would
happen so if I say something like this
and then if I try to assign a value to
it for example let's say 100 now this
one will throw an error message because
you cannot have the your variables
starting with a number but if I used
period and then basically give
something like this
and let's try doing this by giving it a
number so if you see here since we gave
a period the rule is that it should be
followed Always by a letter and not a
number so I could just remove this and
that works perfectly fine so these are
some naming conventions which when you
practice you will learn about so now I
can assign a variable by just doing a
DOT Pairs and then assign any value to
it but always remember if you are using
a period if you are using it notation
then in that case that should always be
followed by a letter one more thing
which is always practiced in a real-time
environment is that we cannot have
spaces
when we are creating variables so for
example if I say first num and then I
try to assign this a value it basically
fails but obviously I could have done
this by doing a underscore and that
perfectly works fine and you can
basically then call the value for this
one always remember one more standard
practice which is followed in real time
environment is you will try to have
variable names with a little meaning to
them so for example if I would create a
variable and I would say for example
let's say bird
that's my variable name and then if I
assign this a value tiger it works fine
but then it really does not make sense
and that would basically create a lot of
ambiguity in our coding so it is always
good to say for example animal and then
I would say okay so tiger is an animal
and that basically not only allows me to
assign a value to the variable but it is
also little bit more meaningful
now when we talk about variables it is
also good to know the different data
types which are available in R now like
any other programming language
R also supports different data types so
you have your logical data types such as
true and false you have numeric values
which is say these numbers you could
also be creating an integer which is 3L
and 40 L for L and so on you can have a
complex number you can have characters
which can be just letters or a set of
letters or anything which is within the
quotes or you can even have raw data so
these are different data types we can
again see quick examples here on data
types let me come out of this one and as
we saw already when we created model one
this was character now I can just say x
and let's say 100 and obviously this is
going to be
not my integer okay so let's see this
what is this one this one by default is
double it is by default double so if I
would want an integer then I would say
for example something like
like this
and this one you can check
by using type off and you can see the
value for this one so this is an integer
so similarly you can have character you
can have complex you can have raw data
you can have numeric values so all these
are different data types you could also
be saying for example I would want to
check the Boolean so I could check this
and select this one and now when I check
the value for a it is true and we will
learn about logical operators where we
can basically be using these values
assigned to the variables to compare to
compute between different variables so
this is a simple small example of using
variables
so we have seen here using variables and
also using the assignment operator and
then assigning values to the variables
and different naming conventions we can
also be using different data types which
are supports
and work with the variables now once we
have learned about variables or data
types let's also just
first learn about your operators and how
they can be used in your R programming
language now we might be intending to do
some calculations on numeric values uh
find out differences between values or
say for example compare values so in
that we can be using different kind of
operators so we have various operators
we have arithmetic operators we have
rational operators we also have logical
operators so before we straight away
look into logical operators understand
about the basics such as your arithmetic
operators which supports for example let
me pull up a notepad file here
and when we talk about arithmetic
operators
here we are talking about your Edition
[Music]
you have subtraction you have
multiplication
you have division
and you have remainder or modulus
and you have exponent
and what makes it also important is that
when you're using arithmetic operators
you also need to know about the order of
operations
So when you say order of operations
always the priority is to parenthesis
so that takes the priority you have then
exponent or your computation if that
would involve exponent
so let's say
exponent end here
which is Then followed by your
multiplication and division
and that one also follows an order of
left to right
whichever comes first when we talk about
multiplication and division and
similarly when we talk about addition
and subtraction
it is left to right
whichever comes first so these are some
of the arithmetic operators now we can
see some examples here quickly although
these are some simple examples so for
example I can say 100 plus 100 and that
gives me the value right you can always
do a hundred minus 50
you can do a hundred multiplication
you could do a hundred division two
or you could also use modulus
to
which basically gives you an error here
so I will oh
just give me net
so let's skip here one more percentage
sign
and that basically says what would be
the remainder
so if we would want to look at the
ordering when we are using this
arithmetic operators we can see an
example so for example if I say 34 plus
divided by 2 gives me 57 however if I
use 34 plus 46 in parenthesis which gets
the priority and then I divide my result
is different so understanding what
arithmetic operators you can use and
also the ordering in which that leads to
the computation is very important so we
can use all of these arithmetic
operators and to control the ordering we
can be using parenthesis or we can have
our computations ordered with what kind
of operation we would want whether that
would be multiplication or division
addition or subtraction now at any point
of time I can always do a control L and
that allows me to clear my console
let's continue our learning and let's
learn about operators
so when we speak about arithmetic
operators we see that allows us to do
computations but we have also rational
and logical operators which help us in
doing our computations or comparing
values or sometimes finding difference
between different values whether those
are group of values or whether those are
individual values so with your rational
and logical operators you can compare
data values so if we would want to see
if the value is matched or not match or
if the values are above or below equal
to something and so on so when we talk
about your rational operators we
basically have
in case of rational or logical operators
rational or logical operators so we
obviously have greater than you have
less than
you have greater than or equal
you have less than or equal
you have equal to
and you have not equal
these are some of your rational
operators we can say
and when you talk about your logical
operators then you have and you have or
and you have not
so and is
when it Compares two values so it
returns true if both the conditions are
true else it will return a false so for
example if I have 10 greater than 20 and
10 is less than 20 now that's not
possible and we are comparing
the result of both of these so we are
checking if both the conditions are true
and that's not really true here so we
see the value as false now if I would
have replaced this one this and with r
it would check
even if one of the conditions is true it
would basically show me a result as true
you can also use a not operator which
takes each element of the vector and
gives the opposite value so we can be
using any one of these operators and
then basically do our computations so
let's see some examples about these
logical operators now either you could
just be assigning values to your
variables and check or you could also be
picking up a data set
from your machine and then try to use
these logical operators so for example
if I say x has been assigned 100
why
has been assigned 200 and if I try to
say X
equals y
so that already checks the value and
comparison tells me that's not true it
is false and if I would have used a not
operator
for example if I would have said
something like
this one
so it tells me true so I can just check
simple conditions like this I can say is
my y greater than x and that tells me
yes it is true
if I say Y is greater than or equal to X
well
it would still say true
because when you are saying greater than
or equal to X so when you are saying
this one it works fine right now we can
also be picking up some data set and for
that what I can do is I can pick up one
of the data set from my machine so I can
go in here and I have some data sets
let's look into that and I would be
interested in taking this auction data
set and loading the values here so I'll
get this path and I will come here I can
use option as my variable name you could
have given it dot separated name for
example I could have said auction dot
data if this is what you want to do and
then you can assign variable a value so
here I'll say read.csv and I intend to
pick up a file so I give this path and
when we are working on Windows machine
we need to give it double slash
so I'll say auction dot CSV now I could
give other things like header being true
what is the separator if you would want
to fill values to take care of missing
values we can look at all of those so
here I'll just add a backslash
I will add a backslash
and I will basically just do a control
enter now I can look at the values of
this by just doing a auction dot data
and I can see what values it has so it
has a lot of data here
it has a lot of your data here you could
have used some other functions which we
can see later where I can choose
head and I can see the first top five
values so we can basically assign
data to the variable and continue
working on this now we can keep it
simple so let me repeat this step and
here I will say auction
as my variable name and I'll assign this
so I can basically do a also a view
on auction
so auction
and then basically that shows me a
tabular format of the data which allows
me to look into the data and basically
understand it and then I can you know
use this to work on variables so what I
can do here is I can say X
and let's say
assign some value to this for which I
would want to work on my data set which
is auction now what do I want to do here
so let's use auction and then I can use
a dollar symbol and I can choose which
column I'm interested in so for example
let's choose bidder
and I can just give a value to this one
and let's pick up a name
so let's say tweak
and that's the name and I can be
assigning all the values to this or I
could say I would want to use another
condition so I'll say option dollar and
then let's take this value of bid
and let's say it is equals to 100 and
then I ended up with comma and I can try
doing this now here it gives me a
problem because what we did was we did
not use the right operator so we will
say for example and
so I will say X
is being assigned the value of
auction bidder being
tweak and auction bed value being 100.
so now once we do this I can look at the
value of x and that shows me the value
so this is just a simple example of
using a logical operator now I could
have just said
instead of and I could have used or
which is basically a pipe
which you have to use
and that gives you or condition and now
hit on enter and if I now look at the
values of X it will show me lot of
values because we have given a r
condition which basically matches one of
the conditions so in this way we can use
logical operators and continue working
and
continue doing our computations
let's learn about print formatting and
how print can be used to view your data
when you talk about r r uses print
function to display the variables so for
example if I have assigned number 10 to
X I can do a print X and that will show
me the value of x what we see here with
1 in square brackets that also has a
meaning which basically means it is a
vector and we'll learn about vectors
later so R uses the paste and paste zero
functions to format strings any
variables together for printing in few
different ways for example if I would do
this which I say Sprint paste and then
pass in
two strings here or two words here such
as hello in world that would be printed
as follows now I could also do a print
paste and then use a separator so my
print would look something like this if
I use page 0 then that avoids any space
between these two words or for example
these three words so let's see some
basic examples here when we talk about
print so for example if I bring up my R
Studio here is an example so X as we say
now this is your assignment operator
which we already discussed now I can be
assigning a value to this so I can just
place my cursor here and I can just hit
on Ctrl enter so value has been assigned
now let's look at the value of x
now I could also be doing a print X
explicitly by using print function for
example if I do similarly for messages
hello and then I can print the message
by using print
now if for example I do something like
this this is not going to print anything
until I call the variable or I use a
print function so for example if I do a
y we see auto printing
shows us the value or I could do
explicitly by using the print function
by explicit printing now whenever we
look at this number one as I mentioned
it means Y is a vector and 5 is its
first element
now you can also use operator to create
integer sequences and we'll learn about
sequences or list later but this is just
a simple example so I am creating an
integer sequence of length 20 I can
place my cursor here which would start
with 10 and end at 30 so let's look at
this values
for our sequence
of integers now at any point of time you
can always use a class
to look at the class
of say x and that shows me the classes
of integers now looking further when we
talk about different data types as we
learned few minutes before so R has
basically
five basic or Atomic classes of objects
so you have character numeric values
that is real numbers you have integers
you have complex and you have logical
values
let's
spend some time in understanding some
basic arithmetic operations and how you
can do it using your R programming
language now here I've opened up rstudio
and these are some basic examples such
as performing arithmetic operations now
for example we can add two numbers and I
can just place my cursor here and please
press Ctrl enter that shows me the
addition I can do a subtraction I can do
multiplication division also going for
exponential power or use modulo which
Returns the remainder now when we are
performing operations what we can also
do is we can change the order of
operations and in this case we are using
parenthesis so I am putting in 500 into
2 in a parenthesis plus 80 divided by 2
so first it operates what is given in
parenthesis and that's why I get a
result 1040 similarly I can change the
order of operation so here I can give
500 into and then something in the
parenthesis so that gets operated first
and hence you get result of 1500 now we
have already discussed about the
assignment operator and what we can do
here is we can assign variables some
value so for example I create a variable
called selling and then I would assign
it a value
similarly for cost and then we can do
some calculation so we can say profit is
selling Minus cost we can do that and
here I can look at the value of profit
which shows me 250. now let's also spend
some time in understanding data types in
R so we can have different types of data
so this one shows me an example of
assigning a decimal value which is part
of a numeric class so I can do this and
then if I would be interested in seeing
the value of num so I can just look at
the value of nump if I would be
interested in looking at the type of num
so I can do that here by just typing in
type of
and then select this one and pass in
your num and it shows me the value is
double I can also look at what class it
belongs to and that shows me
it is numeric so in this way you can not
only assign values to a variable but you
can look at the class and type of it now
here we can assign whole numbers
which are also known as integers now if
I look at the type of this it shows me
double so if I would want to explicitly
assign an integer I could have done for
example I uh let's say J and I could
have used the assignment operator and I
could have done this and then if I look
at the value of J it shows me the value
but what we would be interested in
looking at the class of J so we can do
this and it shows me it is an integer so
explicitly either I can assign this by
using a capital l or I could use a
function called as dot integer so we'll
see that later now we can also assign
Boolean values or basically your
logicals so here we assign true and then
we do a false and we can look at the
type of T and that tells me it is a
logical class now similarly you might be
interested in working on text or string
values and here we can do this by saying
CH and then passing in a value look at
the class of this it tells me it is
the data type is character and if you
look at the type of it it saves me
character
similarly R also supports complex data
types so we can do that too by just
doing this and look at the class of it
it tells me it is complex and you can
also pull out the length of this by
now here we are doing a length on
the character so let's look at this one
and it shows me what is the length of
this now one of the useful functions
which we usually use in R is print now I
can simply do a print hey and that
prints whatever values pass to print I
can assign a value to a variable and
then print it so that is also fine you
could have also without using function
just type Y and that also shows the
value however Sometimes using print as
an explicit function can be useful it
makes your code more readable now here
we would use an inbuilt data set that is
empty cars and then if you would want to
print the data set that shows me the
values which shows me the car models and
different other features such as mileage
cylinder horsepower and so on now one of
the use case of print with a paste
function can also be seen here so I'm
doing a print paste and that basically
prints whatever was passed in a
concatenated way I could also do a print
paste with a separator if I would want
to format my data in a particular way so
here I've used separator as comma there
is one more function base 0 which can be
used so I'm doing here page 0 and that
tells me just concatenate these values
without any space so paste 0 shows no
space between these two elements which
were passed now we can explicitly do
some printing and for that I'm using a s
print F option I am going to pass in
percentage s which is for string and
percentage f for float and we can print
the values of this so these are some
basic operations or usage of your
functions to basically do some
computations or look at your results
so when you talk about basic type of any
R object it is a vector and when we talk
about vectors empty vectors can be
created with Vector function
a vector can contain objects of same
type or a class now when we talk about
list list is a vector which contains
objects of different classes so these
are some basic examples so apart from
your print formatting we can be looking
at what we call as R objects such as
vectors or lists and so on so when we
talk about vectors it is a sequence of
data elements of same basic type we use
the function to declare a vector so we
can always do a c function to declare a
vector for example here we are creating
a variable V1 and we are assigning it a
vector by using C and then giving some
basic types so numbers one to five or
for example words you can always do a
print or you can also use a class
to find out what is the class of the
elements or
the values which have been passed to the
particular object so we can look at some
examples like this for example we can
see here so list is a vector which
contains objects of different classes
so you can have numeric objects so that
is your numbers such as one two Etc
which are your numeric values for
example here what we are doing is we are
assigning a value 1 to a
and that can then be used I can either
do a print or I can just use Auto
printing I can also do
here a value for a i
or I could be doing something like this
which shows me 0
which can be for missing value so if I
would want to use Auto printing I can
just call a and it shows me the value
what has been assigned to it you can
always use a type of
to look at the value of a which is
double by default and if I look at type
of a i that is basically an integer
because we used L here
so in this way we can continue working
with say our different classes
of objects so for example let's create a
vector here so I can say V1 and then
basically assign it by using a c
function and then pass in the values to
this one and that basically gives me a
variable and you can look at what are
the values assigned to it now if I look
at the class of V1 that shows me it is
numeric if you use type of and then you
would want to see the values of V1 that
shows me the values are double now as we
were seeing here we can be looking at
the class so for example if I create one
more
variable and then assign values to it
using C so passing in some words here
for example let's go and say hello world
and then I can basically
do this
and look at the values of this one I
could also explicitly print as we
discussed earlier by doing a print V2 we
could also be having a paste function
if we would want to use that so for
example if I would do a paste function
I could be using
this is missing a bracket so let's
complete this and that shows me the
value I could have also used for example
paste 0 function
and that also works fine
so it depends on what we are looking at
here so if I look at class of V1 which
we had it is numeric and V2 is basically
having Elements which are of the class
character so this is just a simple
example of having your print functions
having vectors created printing out the
values of those printing out class and
type of these
to continue our learning on vectors as I
mentioned earlier we can use the C
function which can be used to create
vectors of objects by concatenating
things together so for example if we
look at this one which says X and then I
use C function and I say 0.5 and 0.6 so
we can have a vector of numeric types so
let's do this
and then we can look at the value of x
so it shows me my Vector which has 0.5
and 0.06 I can also have my Vector of
logical values and now let's look at the
value of x so it has two n false or we
could have done it in this way where we
can then look at the values so we can
use the short form by using capital T
and F
I can create a vector with character
types and then look at the values of
those I can also be creating a sequence
of integers as we saw in previous
example and then look at the values
which start at 9 and end at 29
now you can also create with complex
types and look at the values so these
are some simple examples of creating
vectors now we can also use Vector
function to initialize vectors so for
example if I would do this where I am
saying my Vector will be of type numeric
length is 10 and then look at the values
so it just shows me a vector which has
all zeros and the length is 10. now you
can create a vector of numbers by doing
this as we saw in previous example and
use explicit printing to look at the
values or might be a letters and then
use a print statement to print function
to basically look at the values of the
vector now we can also try concatenating
the above 2 so that creates a mixed
Vector which has two different kind of
types here so I can do a mixed vector by
using the C function and then passing in
my numbers
which has numeric types and letters
which has character types and then we
can basically do a printing of this
which shows me the value but here what
we see is coercion that is basically
casting if you would know as the word in
different programming languages so it
basically coerces the numbers to
character as characters cannot be
coerced into numbers and then you can
print the values of this mixed Vector
where everything is of character types
so for example at this point of time if
I would have done something like class
of mixed
vector
and if I would want to look into the
values of this one it shows me
everything is of character types here
now data type of different vectors can
be returned by the function class as we
saw just now so it is common to use the
class function to integrate an object
asking what is the class now we can
create one dimensional objects such as
an integer Vector which we have done
earlier and then look at the class of it
which tells me it is an integer I can
also create a numeric vector
by giving in some values here so when we
do this
so I have given the vector function C
and then giving in the value and look at
the class it shows me it would have
numeric values now you can create a
character vector and then basically look
at the values of it now at any point of
time in all of these for example if I
would do num I can see what are the
values assigned to it I can do letters
and I can see the values of this so let
me just create some space here now I can
create a factor vector
and then look at the values of it or
also you can see what is the value in
this Factor vector
so here we said as dot Factor so Factor
function is being used here and we are
creating a vector of letters and then we
look at the class we also look at the
values what are assigned to this or what
are in this particular Vector so if you
look into all of these Vector examples
initially we were using an assignment
operator where we were using the C
function and when we started creating
vectors by say concatenating or vectors
of particular types we are using equals
here and that also is fine now looking
further when we look at concatenating
two different kind of vectors so for
example here we have
say
numbers and letters as we discussed
earlier it will do coercion that is
change
one type into other now when we talk
about one dimensional objects we can
have integer vectors or say float which
we saw just now ending at 10.5 so when
we say c 1 is to 10
it basically starts with one but then
there is also you can say a question
happening here and then you have the
values ending at 10.5 that is float and
I can look at the class of it
and when we did a class of
did we do a class here so let's come
here and let's do a class of this one it
says me it is numeric you can look at
the values of it similarly you can
create a character Vector which is
1 to 10 and then basically look at the
class of it or basically the value of
this vector or as we did the factor
Vector now for two dimensionals we will
explore that when we are learning about
Matrix so as of now let's forget that
now when you talk about mixing objects
there are occasions when classes of R
objects get mixed together so that could
be accidentally or that could be
intentional so if you look at this
example here we have Y which has mean
given values which is 1.7 and a and at
this stage if I would look at the value
of y That's My Vector if you look at the
class of Y
that shows me it is as character now
when you look at some other examples so
let's pass in logical and numeric values
what would happen in this case so we can
again
use
class
of Y
and that basically has numeric and if
you would want to look at the value of y
that shows me 1 and 2 here
uh let's go further so let's look at the
value of this one so Y and then
basically see what is the value of y so
it is a
true
and you can also look at the class of it
now we are mixing objects of two
different classes in a vector remember
when we talk about Vector we always talk
about Vector having elements of same
type
but when we talk about lists which we
will learn later that would have
basically or that can have your each
element of different type so for vectors
it is not allowed so when different
objects are mixed in a vector coercion
occurs so that every element in the
vector is of the same class
now we have seen earlier the implicit
coercion where our R tries to find a way
to represent all the objects or elements
as I say so all the objects in the
vector in a reasonable fashion so we can
also be doing explicit coercion so that
is from one class to another by using it
as Dot and then using a relevant
function so if I have X here now if I
look at the class of X it tells me it is
an integer but I can convert that to
numeric by doing a as dot numeric or as
dot logical or as dot character to
basically to a coercion and change the
class of the objects now if R cannot
figure out how to coerce an object this
will result in n a's being produced
which we can also relate to missing
values or not applicable values so for
example if we create X look at the class
of X it tells me this character let's
try changing character to numeric which
will not work and it says n a's are
introduced if you do it even in logical
that would not work and it shows me any
values or if you do a complex it says
values have been introduced so at this
point of time if I look at the value of
x it tells me it was assigned a b c and
we try to convert that into a different
class now when we talk about vectors it
is also good to know about attributes in
brief so all your R objects have
attributes that is metadata for object
so when you talk about R object
attributes you could have names you can
have dimension names you can have the
dimensions that is matrices and arrays
you can look at the classes such as
integer numeric and so on and you can
also look at length which is user
defined attribute so if I say X
we are assigning a value to X now at
this point of time if I see my value to
X is 1 but then all objects need not
necessarily have attributes so in that
case whenever you try to use an
attribute's function that would return
null so at this point of time if I look
at the attributes of X it shows me null
value so these are some of the basics
which help us in working with r and
using your vector function or looking at
the coercion which is implicitly
happening or explicitly can be done by
us by using as dot sum function
now let's learn about lists and how we
can work using r on list when we talk
about Vector which we saw in previous
examples Vector is a one dimensional
array right and it can hold elements
only of same type so we would say Vector
is more of one dimensional but when you
talk about list list is a generic Vector
that can contain objects of different
types
so when you talk about say for example
matrices matrices can also hold elements
of same type but in matrices it is a
two-dimensional array we will talk about
matrices also we will learn so when you
talk about lists they can contain all
kind of R objects so you can have dates
you can have data frames you can have
vectors and many more so in list there
is no coercion which is required that is
changing of data type there is no loss
of functionality and list do not follow
any predefined structure now we can
create lists using this list function as
it is shown here so you can create a
variable and then assign a list to it
where you can be using either passing in
a vector or what you can do is you can
simply create a list by using this list
function so let's see some example here
now for that what we can do is I can
bring up my R Studio
where we can see an example on list and
how it works so when you talk about list
what you can do here is let me close
this one
this one yeah
so what we can do is we can basically
say for example test and I can basically
give
something here so for example I can say
music tracks
and then I can say how many hundred of
them and I can say
let's give 100 as number
and then we can say how many of them got
five stars and I can do this so I can
check this and this shows me all the
objects or elements of this list right
now when we do this what we are doing is
we are creating a vector right and
Vector basically can have coercion
depending on what are the elements which
are passed because whenever you use the
C and you create a vector it will only
accept
elements of the same type so for example
if I do a class on test
it shows me here all the objects are of
type
character right and you can also use
type of
to check
for our test variable and it is
basically having all the objects as
character now how would you create a
list so what we can do is we can use a
list function so for example let's again
do a test here but this time I'm
interested in creating a list and list
can have objects of different types so
let's say music
tracks and then I can just give 100 and
I can save it reading 5 and now if I
look at my test it shows me all the
elements of your particular list here we
see each element or each object with a
double bracket and we can see each
element
now what we can also do is we can use is
list
function and then we can pass and test
here to check what is it and it is a
list right so here we have created a
list but if for example we take the
previous example where we were creating
a vector
and if I would do a is List It would
show me false right so we just created a
simple list and we can also arrange
labels or we can use a name function to
basically give names so what I can do
here is let me create a list first
so I can do that like this and now what
I can do is I can do a name
and I can use a name function to this
test and then basically what I can do is
I can pass labels
so here I can just give in some names
here so for example I can say let's give
it a name
product
so say we are talking about product of a
company and then we can say here I can
give
count
and here I can give rating and this is
basically to given names so let's just
give
some error here let me just check this
so let's use this name function here and
what I'll do is
I will basically use names
and now let's do a test
so that shows me the names what we have
assigned to our list objects
now we can always access the elements of
or objects from a list
using indices or even using double
square so for example I have test here
and basically I can give something like
this which gives me based on the indices
the position
where you are accessing the elements of
the list
so we can do this what I can also do is
we can specify names when creating a
particular list so for example what I
can also do is I can say
product
dot category
and now I can just give list function
so I would want to assign names while
creating a list so I can say for example
product
and this would be
say
music
tracks
then I can give say for example count
and count would be 100 and then ratings
and I can say five
and now we can basically access this
list which we have created so what we
have done here unlike earlier when we
created a list and then basically use
names function to assign a name to it or
each object here while creating a list
itself be passed in the names so we can
also do that
now if you would want to basically list
display the list or
compactly display structure of a list we
can always use the string function and
here I can pass in the name
so let's choose this one and this is in
a more compact way listing down the
elements of your list so list can be
containing other lists also and we can
also do that so for example I create one
more list for example I can say similar
product
and here I can give
a list again and what I would want to do
is I would want to say
product
equals
and I can say film
and then I can basically give a count
and then I can give ratings say four and
here what I've done is I have just
created one more list but my intention
is not just to create a list but I would
want to add this to our existing list so
what we can do here is we can take our
previous list that is product dot
category
like what we did earlier
and now I intend to
say list
and here I would want to
say for example
let's copy this or we can just
so this is what we were doing when we
were creating a list using product
giving the names while creating a list
and what I also want to do is here I
will just say
similar
and then pass in
similar dot brought
so now if you look at
our list we have just added new elements
so this is one more way where we can
create a list and we can basically add
or our list can have other lists so when
we talk about subsetting or extending
list so one of the main ways as I said
to access a specific element or a subset
we use double brackets and we can always
do that so for example we take
our prod dot category and then I would
want to access a particular element so I
can always do this by giving the index
positions and I can access the elements
of my list
so this is one single way now here if we
use a single bracket instead of double
bracket then in that case we will the
output would be a list
so if I look at this one then this would
be a list but if you use double brackets
then you are accessing a particular
object if we were creating a vector we
could just be using a subset by using
the C function
now what we can also do is we can subset
by names or even logicals
so what we can do here is we can take
this product category and if we have
defined names then in that case what I
can do is I can say I would be
interested in music tracks
and this is the name we had given
so we can close this one and we can try
accessing the elements here so we what's
the name we had given so
no it's not music tracks that's the
value the name is product
so we do this and then we can access the
elements what we can also do is we can
be subsetting based on logicals so what
we can do is we can basically just give
something like this and here we can pass
in values
something like this
and we missed a bracket
so that's also a way of pulling out the
value so you can be doing a subsetting
using the names which you have assigned
to objects within your list or you can
say names which you have assigned to the
elements or by using logicals now what
we can also do is we can use the dollar
function now if you see here we are
looking at the name and that is preceded
by Dollar so we can always pull out the
values from our list
by giving the list name and then give it
dollar symbol and then choose the name
for example if I choose product I can
list the values here
I can be looking at say
dollar and then choose account and this
is also one way of accessing your
elements from the list using your dollar
symbol now to add elements to a list as
I said you can add a vector of names and
that can be passed to your list so these
are different ways in which you can work
with list and then you can access the
elements either using indices or using
names or even using dollar symbol and
pointing the right names so this is one
simple example of working with your list
now one more and now I can just do a
control L and I can clear that off so
your list always remember is a generic
Vector that can contain objects of
different types now when we talk about
matrices now Matrix is a collection of
data elements arranged in two
dimensional rectangular layout so we can
use Matrix function to create a matrix
as shown here so Matrix is two
dimensional now we already know that
Vector is one dimensional array of data
elements or a sequence of data elements
but when we talk about matrix it's a
collection of data elements that is two
dimensional arranged in fixed number of
rows and columns so here you see that we
are creating a matrix and we have
specified the number of rows is three
number of columns is 3 and we want it to
be arranged by row where we have given
the value as true
so always remember Matrix is two
dimensional and Matrix can have only one
Atomic Vector type unlike your list it's
a natural extension of vector going from
one dimension to two Dimensions so
Matrix actually needs a vector which
contains values that you place in a
matrix and at least one Matrix Dimension
so we can choose to specify the number
of rows or number of columns when we are
creating Matrix so let's see a quick
example of working with Matrix so for
example I could just say Matrix which
will have values 1 2 6 and then I can
basically give n row
and you can give a value to this one and
that's my Matrix similarly you could
also be giving
n columns so I can just say n call and I
can choose this one and then pass in the
value so that's a matrix where R fills
values column by column now if you
intend to fill up Matrix in a row wise
fashion so that your values 1 2 and 3
are in first row then we have to just
modify this in a little bit different
way so we have to say Matrix
1 colon 6 and rho is two and then I can
give by rho
so you always have these helper
functions which allow you to put out the
values so for example I do this and then
I can do a control enter so now if you
see you have the values 1 2 and 3 in
your first row
so when we pass a matrix function to a
vector that is too short to fill up an
entire Matrix then something different
happens we can have a look at this so
say you pass a vector containing value 1
to 3 to the Matrix function and say
explicitly you want a matrix with two
rows and three columns how do we do that
so for example I can say Matrix and here
I can say 1 is to 3
now I can give n rho
and then I can give the number of rows
which we want is 2 and then I say n
column
and this one I'll say 3
so I can do this and here what I have
done is I have given the values 1 to 3 I
have said number of rows is 2. and your
number of columns is 3. so here R fills
the Matrix column by column and simply
repeats the vector
now if you want to fill using a Four
Element Vector in a six element Matrix
in that case obviously R will generate a
warning message now apart from the
simple Matrix function which we are
seeing
you also have some functions such as R
bind and C bind
which are offers when you are working
with matrices so we can use those so for
example I could say C bind I could say 1
colon 3 and then I can say one colon 3
and that's my C bind that is column bind
where I am passing the values one two
three and which are stacked in a in
columns I can also do R bind and
similarly we can be passing in the
values so I can say R bind and that
basically arranges the values row wise
so be creating a variable for example
let's say n and let me create a matrix
here
so I'll say Matrix now that will contain
one to six
and I can say by row
and then you can give value which is
true and then I can basically say the
number of rows
is going to be 2 and this is also fine
so let's look at the value of n here so
you basically created a matrix with 1 to
6 you arrange them row wise and the
number of rows what you have chosen is
2.
so what we can also do is we can use our
bind and we can add values to it so for
example if I want to add value 7 to 9
what I can simply do is I can do a r
bind I can say I would want to edit my n
and then pass in the values so I can
just do this and this has basically
appended or added values to existing
Matrix so similarly you could have done
a column bind and you could have added
values to your existing Matrix so for
example if I
take this one
and look at my n and what I could do is
I could do a c bind and then I can
basically take my
n
and then pass in values to this one so
let's say 10 and 11. and basically I've
added 10 and 11 as a column to my
existing Matrix so this is one simple
way where you work with a matrix and you
are operating the values either at a row
level or at a column level so let's also
look at some other examples so basically
if you would want to work with Matrix
one of the useful things would be naming
the Matrix that is in case of matrices
we can assign names to either the
columns or the rows if you don't do it
we see the default values here which
follows a numbering but what we can also
do is we can use two functions here one
is row names
or you can use
column names so these are the two
functions which can be used so for
example let's do a control n let's try
to get our n and this is what we are
doing here but what we would want to do
is we would want to give them some names
so for example I'll say row names and
then I will basically pass in a vector
which has row names or vector which has
column names so what I can do here is I
can say I would want to give row names
to n and then I basically give some
value so for example let's say Row 1
and then let's say Row 2 and now I can
look at my n which has the row names
assigned to my rows similarly I could
have also given column names so all I
need to do here is I need to say
column 1 and then I will say column 2
and then I can be using column names
and
let's look at this one so what went
wrong here
so we have three columns here we forgot
that so we have to add one more column
name and then it should be 5. so now if
you look at this one we have just given
row names and column names so naming
The Columns or rows in your matrices can
be very useful now as the previous error
says there is also a function called dim
names
and that's basically an argument
of Matrix function which can be used so
we could also do something like this so
for example I have
dim names so let's have our n
and then what you can do is you can do a
dim names
which you can then just create a list
and in this one you can pass in a vector
for Row one and then Vector for row two
and what we can do here is once we have
given this let's give a comma here
and then give C and then give your
column names which is column one
column two
and then basically
column three
and now if you just look at dim names so
you can just see that you have given
some row names and column names and this
can be used basically to assign to your
list
so if you try to store different objects
in a matrix what would happen
coercion would takes place right so for
example if I have X and let's basically
try to create a matrix which will have
one to eight and let's say the number of
columns
is going to be 2 so let's look at our X
and this has the values now what if I
create say l and then basically I will
create a matrix which will be a matrix
of letters so let's say letters and then
here with letters I'll say 1 colon 6.
now I would want to give the number of
rows
and let's give it say 4 and let's say
number of columns and let's give it
three and now let's look at the value of
L so it has letters and X is having
numbers and what if we bind them
together using C bind which is for
column wise binding so for example if I
do a c bind and then pass in my X comma
l
so if you see here there is a coercion
which has happened where everything is
converted into character so you can
always do a class and you can check so
this is a simple example of working with
matrices there are much more you can do
subsetting like what we saw in list but
that we can learn later
now let's learn about data frames
and what is the data frame and how do
you use R to work with data frame now
data frame is used to store the data in
the form of a table and for this we have
a function data.frame to create a data
frame
so what we know already is that data
sets are comprised of observations or
what we call as instances or variables
and we always have observations to which
some variables are associated for
example we can talk about data sets of
say five people now let's look at the
information here here we look at the
body mass index BMI where we are using a
data.frame function and then we are
passing in say gender so we use the C
function to pass in the values and then
you have height and then you have weight
and age and these things then become The
Columns of your data frame so for
example if we would want to work on
creating a data frame for people where
let's say each person is an instance
and properties about each person such as
name age child or if the person has a
child would become the variables so
if we have such kind of information we
cannot easily store that in Matrix or
list now data frames can be used for
such cases
now it's a fundamentals data structure
to store data sets pretty similar to
Matrix as it has rows and columns and
here rows correspond to observations now
here we can talk about in every
individual or every person
columns correspond to variables that is
properties for each person
now difference between your data frame
and Matrix is that data frames can
contain elements of different data types
so for example we can have one column
being character other being numeric and
yet another being logical or numeric so
restriction is that elements in one
column should be of the same data type
now how do we work with data frames
let's see some examples so what we can
do is we can bring up our r
so when we talk about data frames
usually we don't create data frames by
ourself we import data from data sources
such as CSV file or rdbms or even your
Excel or SPSS and then we create data
frames now of course R has ways to
manually create data frames using data
dot frame function so we can create
three vectors first and then we can pass
in those vectors to create our data
frame so let's do that so let's say name
and here I will use the assignment
operator which we have learned earlier
and then I'll use C and then I can give
some names here so let's say John and
let's say Peter
let's say Patrick
and let's say
Julie
and let's also give one more name so
let's say Bob
so this is a vector which we are
creating and we can check this is the
vector which we have created now
obviously you can do a class and you can
check what is this and that says it is a
vector of character now similarly we can
create one more Vector which is age and
let's give some numbers here so for
example let's say 28 and 30 31
38 35 and these are the values for the
age so age is also created similarly we
can say if each person has children so
we can say
children and then I'll create one more
vector and here I'll give values which
are logicals
I'm not going to give any numerics or
character but I'm using logicals here so
if a particular person has children or
no
so let's have this Vector created
and now we have three vectors that is
name age and children and we can use
this to create our data frame so we can
just call our data frame as DF and what
we can do is we can use data dot frame
function and then what we can do is we
can pass our vectors within this such as
name age children
and that should create my data frame
let's have a look at this and this shows
me that the data frame is created now
column names are inferred from variables
which are passed to data dot frame
function so the variables which we have
passed to our data dot frame function is
name age and children and those become
the column headings for my data frame
now what we could have also done is we
could have created it in a different way
so I could have said DF and then I could
have used my data dot frame function and
in data.frame function I could have said
name is going to be name
age would be age
and then I could say
children
could be
and I could do this and this is also one
more way where I'm creating a data frame
and in this way we can now have rows of
data frames like in Matrix so this is
also one way of creating a data frame to
look into the data frame structure we
can always use Str and then we can pass
our data frame and this basically prints
out
similar to that of list
so we also need to know that under the
hood data frame is a list and in this
case this is a list with three elements
so each list element is a vector of
length Phi corresponding to the number
of observations if we create data frame
with vectors not of same length we would
get an error now here when we look at
our data frame we know that name is a
column so name column which is character
is actually a factor instead of
character
to suppress this Behavior we can always
use a property that is strings as
factors equals false so what I can do is
I can do a data frame like this use my
data dot frame function
and then basically we can pass in our
vectors that is name age and children
and then what I can do is I can say
strings
as factors and set this value to false
so if I do this and now if I look at my
data frame structure
sorry
yeah
now let's look at this one and this one
shows me that unlike your earlier one
now we are creating a data frame where
our name would be containing characters
they are also by default it was showing
as character usually if you because this
value by default is set to false
or it would have created characters or
factors as we say now how do we do a
subset and extend and sort data frames
in r so as we have learned so far in
brief about your data frames
so data frame is somewhere like an
intersection between matrices and lists
so if you would want to subset a data
frame we can always use
the square brackets and in that we can
use the single square brackets which are
from matrices or we can use double
square brackets
from list or we can also use the dollar
symbol so that all these things can be
used to subset a data frame so let's use
our data frame which contains
information about people
so we can select single element from our
data frame so here what we can do is we
can just say DF and then I can use a
single bracket and I can just do a 3
comma 2. so it would be good if we can
first print the data frame and that's my
value and now let's do a single bracket
and let's look at this one so this tells
me that we are
using the row index first which is
number three
which shows me that we would be going to
the row number three and then we point
or pass in our column index that is
number two
so we could have done it in a different
way also so we could have done the F and
then give it row index and then give the
column name which you are interested in
looking at and that also gives me the
value so just like matrices we can
choose to Omit one of two indices to end
up with entire row or entire column and
for example if we would be interested in
looking for information for Patrick what
I could have done is I could have just
said df3 comma and this is showing me
the entire row
now always remember whatever results we
see here that is
giving me a data frame with a single
observation because there has to be a
way to store different data types and
that's why the result is also a data
frame
what we can also do is to get entire age
column we can just use our data frame
and then we can pass in the column name
here
like this and that gives me just the
column now here
the point to notice is result is a
vector because columns contain elements
of the same type in previous example we
were seeing a row and in that row was
not a vector it was a data frame because
values were of different data types now
subsetting a data frame that results in
a data frame and contains multiple
observations can also be done by doing
something like this for example I will
do DF and then I will say let me get
3 comma 5
and then I can just say age and children
for example
so let's say age
and children
and I can be pulling out the values in
this way so I could also be just getting
the results in the age column if I am
interested in by just saying DF and here
I can just pass in the column number and
that also gives me the H column now we
know data frame is a list containing
vectors of same length this means we can
use list syntax to select elements also
and what we can do is we can use our
dollar symbol and then choose the column
name and this is also one way wherein
you can pull out the values or you can
use double brackets as I mentioned
earlier and pass in the column name so
that's also fine or you can give a
column number
and that also would work and in all
these cases result is a vector
now with single brackets you can still
do it always remember if you use single
brackets then that will result in a data
frame
the result can be a data frame here
but what we are seeing here is
a list
which contains only age column having
the data elements so these are different
ways in which you can do a subsetting of
a data frame Now using single brackets
or double brackets can have serious
consequences so we need to always think
about what we are dealing with and how
are we handling it now what we can also
do is we can extend our data frames that
is we can add variables we can add
columns that is adding variables or we
can add rows which are nothing but
observations so adding columns is like
adding new elements to the list and for
which we can obviously use dollar or
double brackets say for example now this
is my data frame and if we would want to
add height whose information is in a
vector so let's say height let's create
a vector here and this one is what I
would want to add for each person so let
me do this and let me pass in some
values here
and the last one
something like this so this is a vector
created now what I can do is
so we have data frame is called DF so we
can say d f dollar
height
and then I will pass in this Vector here
and now if I look at my data frame you
see the fourth column has been added and
that's my height column now what I can
do is I could have done it in a
different way basically
if I had my data frame I could have just
done DF double brackets and then give it
a name and then I could have passed my
Vector in this way however so this is
also one way of doing it we have already
added the column so we don't need to
repeat the step now what we can also do
is we can use
a
C bind function and if you remember C
bind that is for column binding so for
example let's create a weight Vector now
and let's pass in some values here so
for example let's say 75 65 54 34 78 and
these are my values of weight now what I
can do is I can just do a c bind and
then pass in my data frame and then pass
in this vector and in this way I'm just
adding columns or I'm extending my data
frames by adding more columns to it now
obviously if we can use C bind then we
can also use R bind to add new rows so
for R bind creating a new Vector won't
work
because we need to create a new data
frame with one single observation
remember row will have values of
different data types so we cannot create
a vector we have to create a new data
frame and then we can add it using our
bind
so let me create a data frame here for
example let's call data frame storm and
let's pass in some values here so I will
say data dot frame function and then
let's give name
what we can do is we can give age
then we can give the logical value
then we can give say height
and since we have added weight let's
also add weight
and this is my data frame now we can use
R bind function so I can say R bind
and then I can pass in my data frame and
this new data frame which we have
created
and this tells me that the number of
columns of arguments do not match so we
will have to check this one
so we have our data frame which has just
height so it does not have the weight
that was only as the result of C mind so
let's create the storm again without
weight and now let's do a r bind
and let's again check what is the reason
here
so this is height
and let me just check this
so to look at this this is the error we
were getting because I was creating a
data frame with four columns and then I
was trying to add that to a data frame
which had three columns now yes we had
done a c bind and C bind was showing us
the fourth or fifth column but the
original data frame only had three
columns so what I did here was I did Tom
and then basically I
created a data frame with three columns
which matches with my original data
frame
which had three columns and then I could
use R bind to basically add one more row
so what we did was we used R bind and R
bind was used to add a new row to our
data frame now when it comes to sorting
or ordering your data frame say for
example we want to sort data frame by
age now how do we do that so we could
easily do sort DF and then select our
column and we could just do a sorting
now if we do this it is good but not
really what we need now other clear way
of doing that would be using ranks so
for example if I do a ranks and instead
of doing a sort I would use order
and then basically pass in my column so
I would say DF and then I would use h
now in this case if I look at ranks it
shows me a vector of ranks with rank
position of each element now if I do a d
f dollar H it shows me the values and if
you look at the ranks it will tell 21 or
here the lowest value is your 28 and
that's the lowest value and that's why
we see as rank as 1 and so on we can
look at the ranks so what we can also do
is we can just do a DF and then
basically use ranks and we can just look
at the result so this shows data frame
which is a order data frame now based on
ranks now if we would want to do it in a
descending order what we could also do
is we could do a DF and then use order
and with an order I will basically pass
my data frame I will choose my column
and then I could say decreasing
equals true
and I could do this and here this could
show me the value so it says undefined
column names so what I would have to
check is what is my data frame here so
we have age and then what we would have
to do is we would have to select a
particular column so let's do that
and here I have just selected the column
and then there is a comma missing that
was showing an error so now we can have
the data ordered in a descending way so
there are dozens of packages such as
deployer data table which can help you
manipulate filter merge and sort your
data frames so this is in brief about
the data frames working with data frames
subsetting them and also sorting the
data in your data frames
now one more important
type of object in your R is Vector and
that really helps us in various ways so
let's see how we work on vectors here so
to create a vector we can use the C
function and pass in the values those
will be the objects or elements within
the vector and then you can look at the
value of the vector or also at the class
of it which tells me the values are
numeric now in case of vector all the
values have to be of the same type
or belong to the same class we can say
so here we are creating a vector looking
at the value of it and then looking at
the class which says the values passed
in here are character similarly we can
do it for numerics
that is true false and then look at the
value of this and this class is logical
now what we can also do is we can print
all the three vectors at once and here
we will use semicolon to separate two or
more variables and we can pull out the
values of all the vectors with CBC here
now what happens if we pass in the
values which belong to different classes
or you can say different data types So
within a vector if you do that there is
something called as coercion which takes
place which will convert all the values
into one type and in this case it has
converted everything into character
similarly we can pass in values wherein
we can pass logical and numeric and in
this case it's not going to go for
character it is going to convert
everything into numeric
now if I had done this where I passed a
character and numeric and if you look at
this then it has converted everything
into character so character always takes
a precedence if it is one of the values
of vector and you have other values
which are not characters then in that
case coercion will happen
there is one more way of creating a
vector and that is by providing a range
to your C function so we can do that
here
wherein I said c one colon 20 and then
basically look at the value of vector 7
so it shows me all the values starting
from 1 till 20. however there is one
more way you can use the sequence
function to do the same thing
now I could avoid the bracket I could
avoid the C function and I can straight
away pass a range and that is also fine
to create our Vector starting from one
ending at 25.
so what if I want to create a vector
with odd values between 1 to 20 now in
this case I am going to say how many
values to skip or to jump so I'm
creating a variable called odd value I'm
using sequence function and then to that
I'm passing the beginning number the
ending number and then the skip or the
jump and now if you look at the values
it shows me only the odd values well we
could have done the same thing to get
even values and that's not very
complicated so you can start from 2 and
then you can do skip wherein after two
it basically gives you every second
value so we are looking at the even
values and this is how you can create a
vector which is having odd or even
values now what if you want to create a
vector with 10 odd values starting from
10 so you are basically giving a length
so here you can say from where you would
want to start what is your Skip and then
the length of the vector which tells me
it gives me 10 odd values
beginning from 20 or from 20 onwards
that is we take it from 21. now one of
the requirements is always to name the
values so that we can access the values
either by indexing or by their name
which have been passed to the value so
let's see that so let's create a vector
which is called temperature so variable
is temperature pass in the values to
this look at the values of temperature
now what we would want to do is we would
want to assign these names to each value
which makes it more readable more
accessible so I can use the names
function
pass in my temperature as a vector to
names function and then assign the names
to each value of temperature now if you
look at temperature it shows me the
names which have been assigned well we
could have done it in a different way we
could have created a vector of names
something like this and then what I
could have done is I could have created
one more Vector such as temperature and
instead of assigning values we could
have assigned the vector to R existing
Vector so if you do this so you are
assigning the names Vector to the
temperature 1 and now look at the values
it still does the same thing so this is
where you are assigning names to every
value of your existing Vector now there
is one more way and that is using your
sequence so here I'm creating a sequence
which starts with 100 and set to 2020
with a skip of 20 values
or every jump would be 20 values so
let's do that use your names function on
price and then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use my paste 0 option which
takes p and then 1 to 7 as the value so
we know base 0 basically skips the space
and we are going to assign those values
to as names to price and now let's look
at our price so that basically gives me
the names as we desire so these are some
smarter ways of assigning names to every
element or every object within your
vector
now how do we perform some basic
operations let's have a look so let's
create a vector passing in the values
and then you can simply do an addition
on two vectors where each element is
getting added to other element of the
vector you can subtract two vectors that
is element to element subtraction
Elemental element multiplication or
division
and you can basically perform operations
on the vectors now how do we use some
inbuilt basic math functions and that's
pretty easy this is my Vector now let's
do a sum which sums up all the elements
let's find out a standard deviation for
all the values let's find out the
variance for all the values here let's
do a product of vector values find the
maximum or find the minimum value so
these are some basic inbuilt math
functions which sometimes are useful in
our data science or data analysis kind
of activities now one more requirement
might be comparing the vectors using
comparison operators and this is where I
create a vector 1 create a vector 2 and
let's find out the values in V1 which
are smaller than V2 values and that
gives me the logicals as the response
that is false true and false similarly
you can do V1 greater than V2 or you can
say where V1 values are not equal to V2
or equal to V2 so these are some simple
comparison examples now I can create a
different vector and then I can find out
individually if the elements in the
vector are lesser than 3 by just doing a
v lesser than 3 so it Compares each
element with this so you are actually
using one scalar value to compare it
with all the elements and you can do
that it gives you the logicals so you
can also
be doing slicing and indexing on vectors
and this is very much important when you
are storing your data in vectors how do
you access them so let's create a vector
using sequence let's give it some names
as we have seen in past and let's look
at our price one so that tells me the
name and the values now you can access
the elements using indexing so let's get
the third element
and it shows me 590 remember the
indexing here starts with one unlike
other programming languages like python
where indexing starts with zero now I
can also get the third and fourth value
by doing a three colon four I can also
specify the vector and say 1 comma 4 and
that shows me the first and the fourth
position or second or sixth position so
this is one way where you are using
indexing to access the elements
similarly I can give the names now
that's where we see the benefit of
giving names to every element so I can
use C function pass in the name and look
at the value for that particular name or
selectively select different columns or
different names
or we can also use this square brackets
wherein we pass the names
so sometimes it can also be useful to
use logical positioning that is we would
want to find out the logical position if
the value exists and we can do that
or using true and false and then look at
the values
so there is one useful way where you can
exclude a particular position might be
that is an n a value might be a value
which you are not interested in and
that's where you will say minus 2
which will skip the P2 value or minus 2
N minus 5 where we are skipping a P2 and
T5 and we can exclude particular values
from our Vector now how do we do a
comparison operator on the values of
vector so you can just say price 1 and I
would want all the values which are
greater than 600
or you can assign this to a filter and
then basically pass in the filter for
your
vector so these are some simple basic
operations which you can run
using your R programming where you would
want to manipulate where you would want
to store some data and extract that data
use your different logical operators or
other operators and perform your basic
easy computations
now that we have seen some basic
operations using R let's look at some
more operations when you're working with
vectors such as one of the common issues
is handling the missing values now here
we are assigning a vector to a variable
order detail and this one has a missing
value now let's see how this is handled
and you see all the values in the vector
are assigned what you can also do is you
can assign names as we have seen earlier
by using the names function and then
look at the value of order detail so you
see the names and these are your missing
values which are also taken care now
what we can also do is we can perform an
operation on a particular Vector which
will be applied to all values of the
vector so for example here I will just
add a scalar Value Plus 5 to the
elements in the vector and that shows me
number Phi has been added to each
element or each object in the vector now
if you would want to work on two vectors
for example to add two vectors let's
create a vector called New Order and
then let's add it to order detail now in
this case what we are doing is we have a
vector which is from 5 to 10 and what we
are doing is we are adding values to
order detail now our order detail
earlier was 10 20 30 n a 50 and 60 and
what I have done is I have passed in a
vector which is 5 and 10 and you are
adding it to the elements so 5 gets
added to 10 and then your value 10 gets
added to 20. and then you have again 5
which is added to 30 now you cannot add
in anything to a missing value so that
remains as it is then you add again 5 to
50 and then 10 is added to 60. so in
this way you are adding two vectors
which are not of same length but you are
adding these values now what I can also
do is I can update the order
by knowing this so I am creating an
update order
and now let's look at the value of
update order what does it show so you
are basically doing the same thing
so
if you would want to work on a subset of
vector how do you do that so here you
are using some indexes so I am saying
order detail and this is my order detail
so let's take one colon 2 and assign it
to first two so if we look at the value
which is assigned to first two we have
just sliced and added a subset of vector
to this one and if I would want to take
the length of order detail it shows me
the length here which is six elements
here
including the missing value also what we
can also do is we can do some more
operations so for example from order
detail what I am doing is I'm saying
length minus 1 and then
up to the length so let's do this and
let's see the result of this so what we
have done is we had our order detail
which had these values and what we have
done is we have said length minus 1
colon length so you have taken these two
elements and you have assigned that to
your B1
similarly we can do length minus 1 and 2
elements so I can do this and now let's
look at the value of V2 so this shows me
the value where you are taking length
minus 1 and then you are taking it till
the second position of the index element
which is 20 so you are getting in the
values here so you get your 50 n a 30
and 20 because you started with length
minus 2 and up till the second index
position
similarly we can use the length and we
can take it from
this element and let's look at the value
of V3 so that shows me that I am I'm
doing some slicing or I'm getting subset
of my Vector so similarly you can also
do this one so V4 and let's do this and
then let's look at the value of V4 so it
gives me the values based on our
subsetting or slicing now you can
extract all the values below 30 and this
is where you are doing a comparison so
you will take your vector and then you
would want to compare each value if it
is less than 30 and you would want to
take all the values here so it gives me
the logicals or the response for all the
values which are lesser than 30 what we
can do is we can also use the square
brackets and do this this will show me
the actual values here we were just
getting the logicals but here we are
getting the values now to Omit any value
from the vector we can use n a DOT omit
and this one will help me in getting rid
of the N A values plus I am also
checking the values if they are less
than 30 and then I am basically doing
using this n a DOT omit
so you can do something like this you
can look at the values what you can also
do is you can find the order details
that are multiples of 3 and here we
would want to use modulus and we would
want to find out if the remainder is 0
then I am getting the numbers which are
divisible or multiples of three so let's
do this and it gives me again The
Logical values of all the values which
are divisible by 3 giving us a remainder
of 0 or if you would want to look at the
values then you can say order detail
open up a square bracket and then pass
in your condition
now we can then omit n a from this one
and then we can look at the values
so this is simple way where you are
subsetting a vector or extracting the
values which you are interested in which
might be one of the requirements of your
data wrangling or data manipulation or
just data extraction
now I can also use a sum function now if
we do this it returns n a because there
is already a missing value and you
cannot do a sum on the values
now what I can do is I can do a n a DOT
r m to remove the N A values so I can do
a sum on order detail where I intend to
add up all the values but what I also
want to do is I want to remove the any
value so I'm giving it a value as true
and then if I do it it gives me the sum
of all the values so similarly you can
do a mean you can do a maximum you can
find out the minimum value standard
deviation or even square root now these
are some simple operations what we are
doing on Vector where we are interested
in extracting some specific values now
let's look at Matrix which we have also
discussed and Matrix is also one way
where you can use the Matrix function to
create a matrix which is
multi-dimensional so for example if I do
this and if I look at the value of v i
get a matrix which starts with the value
of 20 ends with 30 and at any point of
time you can convert this to Matrix so
first we created a vector and now I'll
create create a matrix out of it wherein
I am seeing the row numbers I am seeing
the column number and I am seeing the
values in that particular column
so you have already done that now let's
take it to the next level so let's
create a matrix wherein we are using the
Matrix function we will say 0 comma 3
comma 3 and now let's look what it has
done so you have created a matrix which
is of three columns and three rows and
by default the row number and column
numbers have been assigned to them we
can also create a matrix by passing in
values so we can say one colon 9 and
then give the dimensions that is number
of columns is 3 number of rows is three
and if I look at the Matrix now I have
passed in the values to my Matrix so
sometimes you may want to arrange the
data in a matrix for particular kind of
calculations you can also use n row and
Biro so you can say how many number of
rows you would want and you would want
to assign the data row wise so when we
are doing this now if you notice the
difference between the previous one
where we just gave the values and we set
three rows and three columns so it was
doing it column wise so one two three
four five six seven eight nine but here
we said by rho is true so it has
arranged the values in a row wise
fashion so it goes one two three four
five six and seven eight nine
similarly I could have just done this by
giving the dimension and selecting by
row and if I do this it is still doing
the same thing
now what we can also do is we can create
Matrix using vectors
so here let's create a vector stock one
and then stock 2 now
we would want to merge both the vectors
so you can always do a c function and
then create a new Vector that is stocks
which is emerged result of stock 1 and
stock 2 and let's look at the results so
that's my stocks that's a vector and now
what I would want to do is I would want
to create a matrix using the stocks so
I'm giving it a name that is stock dot
matrix I'm using the Matrix function
wherein I will pass my Vector I will say
by row so I want the values to be
arranged row wise and I am also
selecting the number of rows
so if you look at this one so the values
which we had in our stock which was all
the values have now been arranged row
wise and in two rows so it starts with
450 51 52 45 and 68 that's my first row
and the rest five values are arranged in
the second row so one of the main
requirements is instead of going for
default column names and default row
names we can give specific names to our
columns and rows to make more sense to
the data how do we do that so we can
basically say days
so this is a vector which we are
creating and then what we want to do is
we want to create a new variable which
is stock 1 and stock 2.
now
this is for my columns and this will be
for my rows now how do we assign that so
we can say column names and this is
where I will say on my stock dot matrix
I will assign days which has five values
and that will become my column names and
similarly using row names function I can
basically assign row names to my Matrix
so if I look at my Matrix now it shows
me the column names and row names which
we have assigned or which we have passed
to our Matrix
now there are different functions which
are associated with the Matrix and let's
look at some examples so these are some
simple basic examples now if I say let
me find out the number of rows and that
gives me the number of rows or number of
columns or get a dimension that is the
number of rows and Columns of your
Matrix now we might be just interested
in getting the row names or column names
or even the dimension names which
basically will give me
Returns the row and column names
so in this way you can use these symbol
functions which are associated with
Matrix to extract information about your
Matrix or data which has been
transformed into Matrix to pull out some
information about that one of the
requirements
which data scientist or data analyst
might face is carrying out arithmetic
operations on your Matrix now what we
can do is we can create a matrix which
takes values 1 to 50 we want to arrange
it by rows and we will say number of
rows is 5 so that's my values starting
from 1 now I can do a addition
here by just doing a 5 plus Mac one and
if you notice number five as a scalar
value has been added to every element of
the Matrix similarly you can do a
multiplication you can do a division
you can basically return the quotient if
you would want to do that or go for
exponential values so you can perform
simple arithmetic operations for every
element of The Matrix
and what if you want to have arithmetic
operations done on multiple Matrix so
let's create mat1 plus matte one and we
get a total where every element is added
to every element you can do a
subtraction you can do a multiplication
and you can get the value so this might
be also very useful when you are working
on multi-dimensional data
you can also
do some more operations on Matrix such
as Returns the sum for each column
say you are doing a summation or at a
row level or you want to do a mean for
every row you can do that by using these
simple functions
now you can add rows and columns to a
matrix using R bind and C bind functions
so R bind is for row bind and C bind is
for column bind but for that we have to
first create a vector so let me create a
vector of same length
which will then be added to every or
added as a row to my existing Matrix now
my Matrix has five columns so let's
create a vector with five elements and
then I can basically add this as a row
to my existing matrix by doing this and
now if I look at my values I will see
the new values at this as the third row
and if you also see the variable name
becomes the row name and we have added a
row to our Matrix now similarly I can
find out row means that is we have seen
earlier by calculating the mean or
average so I can do that and I can find
out the value of average now what I can
do is I have got the average for every
column and what we can do is we can
basically do a column bind by using a c
bind function and I will say I'm going
to take the total stock which has three
rows and then get the average and now
let's look at the total stock which
shows me the average value which is the
new column which has been added to the
Matrix so these are some simple very
simple operations which you can do but
that gives you good Insight in what can
be done at a matrix level where your
data is arranged in multi-dimensions now
how do we do a selection and indexing in
Matrix so in vectors we were using
either names or we were using positions
or we were using indexing now here let's
create a matrix called student and we
are using the Matrix function but within
the Matrix function we are using the C
function to create a vector which will
pass in all the values which also has
any values if you close notice we will
split these values into number of rows
is 4 so that means the values the number
of values in this Vector should be a
multiple of 4 I'm saying columns is 4
and I would want to arrange this data
row wise so I've done that and if you
would want to get the dimensions out of
this so I can do a dim names so what I'm
doing here is on my student I am
assigning a list which will basically
have these names
which are basically assigned and now if
you look at your student it basically
shows me
the values which were first applied to
the row names that is John Matthew Sam
and Alice and then you have one more
Vector which goes as the column names
for the values so you have not only
created a matrix
by using a vector by defining your
Dimensions that is number of rows and
columns you have arranged the data in a
row order and what you have also done is
using a list function you have passed in
the values which will be applied as row
names and column names to your Matrix
now how do we extract particular columns
here so we can take our Matrix and we
can just say comma 1 and that basically
gives me the values for John Matthew Sam
and Alice and what we are looking at is
the First Column now I can also say from
First Column onwards I would want to
look at how many columns so I can do
this and now here I'm selecting first
and second column I can also be using a
vector function here and that also does
the same thing where I am saying 1 comma
3 and I am getting the values from first
and second column so third is not
included here
now if you would want to do row wise
then you have to give the row position
first so if I do a student one that
gives me the row values and this is
giving me values for my student which we
are seeing here so for John we have 20
30 Na and 70 and that's what we get here
when you do is row wise operation you
can also do a row wise and how many rows
do you want
you can use the vector function to do
that you can also select or slice out a
value
where you are getting an intersection of
Row 2 and column 2 and then you can also
start from a particular position and
then onwards get your rows
so these are different ways in which you
are slicing the values from your Matrix
by columns or by rows
so
at this point of time let me just type
in student here and let's look at the
value of student and then here we are
interested in three colon 4
and then 2 colon 3 so what does that
give me so you are looking at
third to fourth row so you're looking at
Sam and Alice and then you are looking
at columns 2 and 3 so that basically
gives you your 26 32 24 and a
so first is you are giving your row
positions or how many rows you want and
then you are giving your column so
similarly you can do this you can say
from row number two to four and then
column wise you can say one two three so
if we do this so this tells me two
columns which is first and second and it
shows me rows which is
from second to Fourth
so in this way we can extract data based
on rows and columns now if we would be
interested in finding out a specific
value so for example if I again bring up
student
this is my student and what I would be
interested in is getting the value of
John and for specific subjects so maybe
we are looking for
two column three now if I do this it
shows me for John and what we are
interested in is two column three so
that gives me the value for chemistry
and biology so you are giving the
columns so row wise you have already
specified the name and that basically
selects the particular row I could have
given a number and chosen which row or
which rows we would want to pull out the
values now if I would want to find out
the value for John and Sam
now in that case
I could use indexing or positioning but
that has to be continuous but here you
are talking about John and Sam which has
methu in between so we will basically
create
we will get the values for John and Sam
and then we will look at the value 4 now
that is basically giving me the values
in the fourth column which is 70 and 75.
similarly if you go further you can look
at maths and bio score of Sam and Alice
so you will give your row names that is
Sam and Alice and then you would want
the values for maths and bio so that is
basically your third and fourth column
and we can do that by looking at the
values
how do you find out an average well
that's pretty simple you can use the
mean function
on student
you will select your row name that is
John you also want to get rid of any
values otherwise that will give a
problem so you get rid of that by saying
n a DOT r m
equals true and then you get the average
score of John now how do I do further
computation that is if I want to find
out the average and total score of all
students so in this case I can apply or
I can use an apply function here I am
saying I'm working on student
and we would want to give the row number
that is 1 and we want to also give the
columns so I want to find out mean
I want to remove or get rid of the na
values and now if I look at help apply
it tells me how does the apply function
works over array margins so I will do an
apply function on student where I would
want to select the first row
I would say I want the sum
and I want to get rid of the N A values
so this gives me the sum for each
student
and here we are getting a mean value
which was for
each student
so what we are doing here is for example
let's look at student again just so that
we avoid confusion so we have student
and then we have physics chemistry bio
maths and I have said Row one so
basically what we want is for John we
want the total and what we can do here
is we can say 20 plus 30 avoiding n a
and then 70 that gives me 120 then you
look at Matthew so this is again doing a
totaling there is no n a value and you
look at the value right so when we have
chosen apply function we have worked on
student now here we are interested in
the values that is sum of all the values
for this particular row
I am saying take care of any and then
give me a sum similarly you did a mean
and that was giving you a mean for each
student
so these are some simple operations now
what we can also do is we can basically
create a vector called passing score
and what we would want to do is we want
to get the values or find in how many
subjects Alice has passed how do we do
that we will have to compare Alice score
which should be greater than
or equal to the passing score so what we
can do is we can create a variable here
pass now I am saying student I would be
interested in the values for Alice so I
have mentioned that row name here I am
then comparing it with passing score
which we have created here and that will
give me the values wherever Alice has
passed in a particular subject
now I can obviously get rid of the N A
values and then look at this which
basically tells me there was one subject
in which Alice passed and rest were
either false or any
now same thing we can do for Sam
so Sam is here and what we want to do is
we want to look at the values here so we
will say let's do the same thing for Sam
and find out the comparison with passing
score and get rid of any values so you
are basically extracting value so these
are some easier operations and usage of
functions on your matrices which are
filled in with values at row level and
column level and then you can apply one
of these functions or multiple functions
to basically extract value which makes
more meaning
so that's with your Matrix now let's
also look at data frames now data frames
as we know is basically data which has
been ordered in rows and columns
wherein we can assign row names we can
assign column names we can do some
operations on data frames so let's look
at example so if I do a data here so
that gets me some sample data sets or
functions what we have here
so let's do
once we have our data here so it says
use data package and then you can get
list all the data sets and available
packages and you can basically look at
all the r data sets which we are seeing
here it has opened up so I would be
interested in getting the air passengers
data so I'm going to pass that in the
data function and then if I do a head to
see the initial data from Air passengers
it shows me the values what we have
similarly we can do that on Iris data
set and look at the head values I can do
a view to look at specific values in a
tabular format if that makes more
meaning and that makes it easy for
analysis now I can do a view on State
x77 and that basically shows me the
population income and all this for
different U.S states so these are some
different data sets what we have you can
do a view on them to basically
understand the data or look in a more
readable format you can just do a tail
to get some end data so head and tail
functions just give you the top six
entries or basically your entries from
that particular data set now the
question is how do we work on this data
so I can get a statistical summary so I
have the iris data set which we had here
so if I do a head it shows me Iris data
set this is a popular data set which
shows The Petal lens sepal length of
particular flowers and the species what
is the length what is the width and what
species does that flower belongs to okay
now here we can get a summary that is
statistical summary of a data set which
gives me mean first quartile median mean
third quartile and maximum values it
basically shows you the count of the
entries for each species what we have
under the species column now what I can
do is I can check the structure of this
data set using Str
I can create a data frame now of this
data using the data dot frame function
so for that we need to also have say for
example if we would want to create a
data frame let's see how do we do that
so first we create a vector of days
we can create a vector of temperatures
and rain and then we want to create a
data frame out of this so I use the data
dot frame option I pass in my days Temp
and rain as the vectors and now if you
look at the data frame you basically see
that I have my days my Temp and rain so
those were the variables those were the
vector names and those have become the
column names row names are Auto assigned
and basically we are seeing the values
which have been passed in my data frame
now I can do a summary on this to
basically look at what is the length or
how many values we have in data frame
what is the class of elements so that is
character you are looking at your values
or summary which gives you mean first
quartile median mean and so on and then
it also shows you the complete data on
rain
what is the mode here
what how many false or how many True
Values we have you can also look at the
structure of this data frame by doing a
SDR
which gives me how many objects we have
how many variables we have what are the
different variables so that is days
temperature and rain and the values for
those for days if you notice it is of
the type character temperature is
numeric brain is logical now how do we
do data frame indexing so like your
Matrix which basically has rows and
columns and in multi-dimension similarly
in data frames also you have indexing so
you can do a data frame so I could just
extract the first row by doing this and
that basically gives me the value so you
can always compare it by just typing a
DF so that's my data frame and now let's
look at the values extract the first row
and that shows me Monday 25.6 rain value
is true now I can also do it column wise
so for example I could do it in this way
so here what I'm doing is I am doing
extracting the second row from this one
so it tells me
25.6
30.1 40.0 37.3 so you have extracted the
values for the column right so I would
not say extract the second row you would
say extract the second call
okay so this one should be second column
yeah now selecting using column names so
that's the easiest way to extract the
values for a particular column so I can
just do this instead of giving the
position of the column or the column
number I'll give the column name and
that gives me all the values of
temperature
and if I do this where I am saying 2
colon 4 and then I'm giving the columns
so it gets me the second
third and fourth rows for day and
temperature
and we are looking at the values so you
have given your row names and then you
have selected your columns you can also
do a dollar sign if you would want all
the values of a particular column so I
can just do a d f dollar days or DF
dollar rain and it shows me the values
from my data frame now one more way of
doing that is using your bracket
notation to return a data frame format
of same information so if you want the
resultant data in a data frame format
you can just do a DF rain or DF
temperature and that is basically giving
a data frame so if I had assigned this
to a value and if I had look at the type
of this that would be data frame now one
of the things which we also require is
filtering data frames using a subset
function
so that is subsetting the information
from a data frame so we know we have our
data frame let's look at our data frame
again so that just reminds of what data
values we have and here let's get a
subset out of it using the subset
function so I'm passing in my data frame
I am saying I would be interested in the
rain column so I am giving subset rain
column and wherever the values are true
so returns all the columns where it has
rained
similarly I can do a subsetting by
giving a value for temperature wherever
the value is greater than 25 and that
shows me the value so this is where you
are filtering the data in data frames
using a subset function to which you
have to provide a column name and then
giving a condition now one more
important thing which might be required
is sorting your data frame using order
function so I can create a variable my
name sorted dot temp I want to do a
ordering of data frame and here I am
doing a ordering based on temp
and now if I look at the value
or I can create this
in an ascending order
so let's look at the values and now if I
look at my data frame it just gives me
the order or the ranking for the
particular values
so we have discussed this in other
section also so what I can do is I can
return all the columns with temperature
sorted in a descending order so right
now what we were seeing was we were
seeing in ascending order but what we
can do is we can do that in a descending
order so here I am creating a variable
descending dot temp I am doing a odd
ring but when I am doing a ordering I am
using the minus symbol and this one if
you would look at in the form of a data
frame it shows me the values which are
ordered in a descending order based on
the temperature column
now another way of sorting is by using a
particular column
so what I can do is I can sort I can do
a order and then I can choose the column
based on which I would want to order it
and then if you would want to get the
values of this so it tells me the values
have been ordered based on depth
so this can be very useful when you
would want to sort the data or order it
in a particular way to basically
understand your data or to make more
meaning out of it right similarly one
more requirement might be merging your
data frames
so here I am creating a data frame so
I'm saying authors and I'm using
data.frame function and what we are
doing is instead of creating three
vectors I am basically doing that within
my data frame function so let's do that
and now what we can do is at this point
of time I can check what my authors look
like so this is my authors now here if
you see we have
the vector turkey venables Tierney
Ripley and McNeil so that becomes my
first column
which is surname then you have your
nationality and then you have deceased
where you have also
repeated the values four times right so
that's something new which you might be
seeing so you are creating a vector
where you are passing in a value and for
other set of values you are basically
using an repetitive function now
similarly we can create a data frame
called books and this one is where I am
having name column title and then I have
other dot author and you are passing in
the values so at this point of time if
you would want to look at your books
it would look something like this so you
have given a name now just closely look
at the data frame function so here you
are using the names you have the titles
whatever values you are passed in always
remember when you have multiple vectors
they are ending with a comma right so do
not forget that and then you have other
dot author so that's the name of the
column and you are passing in the values
where you have also passed some n a
values and at this point of time you can
look at authors this is your books and
Our intention will be to merge these
data frames so that's what we would want
to do my BBB are interested in getting
the data together so what I am doing
here is I am saying M1 now I want to use
the merge function I pass in my data
frames that is authors and books
so if we closely look at authors it has
three columns and five rows and here you
have three columns and we have seven
rows so we would want to do a merge so
we'll say authors books and we will say
by dot X so this is where I am choosing
which is the column based on which I
would want to merge so I have by dot X
which is surname
and by dot Y which is name
so we would want to merge the data where
we are giving a condition based on
values in surname and name so you see
there is turkey here there is turkey
here we have venables we have venables
we have Tierney we have this one we have
Ripley which we have here multiple
entries and then you have MacNeil
now we don't have R core which is there
in your author so let's see what happens
when we do emerging here
okay and now we see the result of this
merge where it has taken all the values
from both the data frames so you have
surname nationality deceased you get the
title you get the other dot author which
you are getting in from your books and
the name column is avoided right because
we are doing the merging based on
surname and but y dot name is name so we
don't see the name column but what we
are seeing here is the values which have
been merged and then you can compare so
for example let's do a random check so
if I look at macnill that's the surname
or here it was named so you have magni
you have a nationality which comes from
the First Data frame deceased from the
First Data frame then you have your
interactive data analysis and then you
look at title.author what you don't look
at in the merge is this R core because
this does not have any value in your
author's data frame so you can do a
merging of your data frames using the
merge function so please try it out and
you can create different data frames and
try to use this similarly you can
manipulate a data frame so for example
here we are creating one more data frame
called sales report
which is data dot frame you are giving
an ID product has some values unit price
is where you are
getting the values as integer and
quantity as integer so now if I look at
my sales report this is the values which
I have let's spend couple of seconds to
look at this value so ID value is 1 0 1
2 1 0 10 product is a b so that is
automatically assigned unit price is
starting where you say 1 0 1
184 right so we are using a as dot
integer we are converting it into
integer and basically we are
assigning these values here
for your unit price and similarly for
quantity we are assigning the values by
doing a as dot integer and then just
doing a run F now once we have done that
we have created a data frame now how do
you transpose what do you mean by
transpose so transpose is when you are
changing your accesses so if I do a
transpose on sales report
and if I want to do a view so you will
see the positions which have changed so
you have all these values so my row
names are row whatever values become the
column headings and basically your
column headings becomes your row names
so that is what you're achieving by
doing a transpose you can do a head to
look at some initial values you can do a
sorting of this data frame by using the
order function and you can choose the
column and also the order if you would
want to have it in ascending or
descending or basically increasing or
decreasing values you can also choose a
particular column like we are choosing
product as a column and I would want to
take the values of sales report in a
descending order that is unit price
and we can just do ordering of data
frames or sorting the values in data
frame so this is pretty easy please
spend some time in practicing these
things taking these examples and you
will learn more about these functions
you can always try creating an example
at your end and you can try to look into
these now what about subsetting the data
frame so when you are saying subsetting
the data frame let's do a subset
function like what we used earlier I
will say subset dot product a I'm using
the subset function and here I will get
the subset based on the product value
being a
let's look at this and this shows me
only the values where product value
matches a
now extract the rows for which product
is a and your price is 150 so you are
still doing a subsetting you are still
passing your data frame here you will
give the product as a which will tell
basically the values for product and
unit price greater than 50 so you are
giving some conditions and look at the
values
now if you are only interested in
particular columns so if I say only the
first and the fourth column product is a
and unit price is 150 so you have to
still use your subset function pass in
your data frame product will be given as
a and unit price should be greater than
150 but what I am interested in is the
values from the first and the fourth
column and now if you see it shows me
the values for my fourth column what we
can also do is we can create two subsets
so set a from data frame where we take
the product is being a other one is
being B and then we can look at the
values so this is just a this is just B
and what we can do is we can combine
them or we can merge them using column
bind so when I say column bind and I'm
saying set a set B so it is basically
going to stack the data frames column
wise and if you do R bind it is going to
stack the data frames row wise
so we can either use
column or we can do a row wise
so this is in one way where you can
merge the previous example where we saw
merging was based on a particular
condition which is met based on some
columns which might have similar values
right and this is where you are straight
away merging the data frame using column
bind and C bind so if you compare this
with the other merge operation what we
saw here this was where you are
comparing the values of
First Data frame and second data frame
and then merging but here we have just
used column mind and row bind so we are
not merging on a particular condition we
are just stacking them either column
wise or row wise
now what we can also look at is doing
some aggregate operations this is going
deeper into Data frames so when you use
aggregate function you are passing in
your data frame you are choosing the
quantity column and then you are
basically using the list function so
list function is going to work on your
data frame on the product column so
product column for your sales report so
at this point of time let's look at
sales
report
and let's look at the value here so this
is my sales report and what we want to
do is we want to aggregate the values on
quantity column
but for that I will say I will just take
the product columns and I will get a sum
wherein I'm ignoring the any values
let's look at this and that gives me an
aggregation value so remember aggregate
function is doing a summing up now here
we are doing a summing up on your
product
that is sales report product column is
what we have so you are kind of grouping
by based on products so we have two
products here A and B now what we also
want to do is we want to take the
quantity column so that's why we have
given that first and what we are doing
is we are doing a summing up so we are
summing up all the values for a and all
the values for B and we are seeing that
here if there are any n a values we are
ignoring it so these are some basic
operations on data frames or matrices
subsetting them extracting useful
information
using some inbuilt functions to do
transformation or computation and
extracting some values
now similarly we can also work on lists
now that we have looked at data frames
matrices vectors let's also look at one
more structure and how we work in R when
we have to work on lists so list is
basically a structure here and what we
are doing is we are creating a list by
using the list function and here I am
passing in three vectors you see here
now C function is being used now in
Vector we know that all the elements are
of the same type now let's create a list
wherein we see three vectors which are
of three different types or objects of
three different types so let's create
this list
and now let's look at our list so it
basically has elements wherein you have
values of different types we can create
a different list which can also have
sequence elements that is one to ten a
matrix which is of three dimensions and
then also passing a list so this is also
one way of creating a list let's look at
list two and if we look at the values
here list 2 basically has a vector which
has values 1 to 10 it has a matrix of 3
into 3 it has a list which has values a
having 10 and B having 20. so this is
how you can create a list which can have
objects of different types so we can
also
use recursive variable a variable that
can store value of its own type so for
that you have to use a recursive
function something like this so I'm
saying is recursive and then do it on
your list
and we can check if the list basically
has a variable that can store values of
its own type now
one of the main requirements when you're
working with list is indexing so I have
created a list and here I can access
this Elements by using a index so if I
do this this shows me the Matrix what I
could have also done is using the dollar
symbol and then
choosing
particular element of the list by doing
a mat which is the name given to our
Matrix or by choosing a name that is
Vector so you can access the elements
using indexing or dollar rotation or
giving the name of a particular element
now I can also work on list and I can
get the third elements second value so
we can do that and that shows me 20 or
you could have done by giving the value
that is the third element and within
that you are looking for second element
so I can get the length of the list I
can get the class of the list which
shows me this type list and what I can
also do is I can convert vectors into
list so here we are creating a variable
price which is being assigned a vector
which has 10 20 and 30 and now what I
want to do is I would want to convert
this Vector into list and for that I'm
using the list function so I am creating
a variable called price list and then I
am saying as dot list so that's going to
convert my Vector into list and now
let's look at price list
which shows me
a list or you can look at Price which is
a vector so that's when you are
converting your vector into list now how
do you convert your list into vector and
that also can be done by doing a unlist
function so I can basically work on
price list wherein we converted Vector
to list and I can just do a unlist on
that which will convert my list into a
vector looking at the values of the
vector now sometimes we may want to get
the dimensions so we can use the
dimension function to convert the
vectors to a matrix so that it can have
multiple Dimensions so here we create a
vector which has four values and then I
am going to give a dimension to this so
that it is converted from Vector into
matrix by giving Dimensions 2 comma 2
and now if you look at Price 1 it has
basically changed into rows and Columns
of two into two Dimensions so these are
some simple examples of working with
list now when you talk about basic data
type functions we have seen how you use
the assignment operator
how you get the data type of a
particular variable or the class to
which it belongs I can assign different
values
such as 10.5 so the previous one was
showing me the value numeric and now
what we would want to do is we want to
assign a value 10.5 look at the class of
it it says numeric type of it shows
double so by default it belongs to the
double class now I can check if the
values in N1 are numeric and that shows
me true and similarly for N2 and that
shows me 2. so you're using the numeric
function which returns true if the given
value is numeric
similarly we can have integer assigned
to a particular variable and for that
either I can do as dot integer or I can
assign a value with capital L so I can
do this and look at the value of i1
similarly I2 and look at the values and
if I would want to check if that is an
integer
let's look at the values of
I2
which was an integer i1 which was an
integer ni3 which is an integer so here
we have assigned integer values to a
particular variable now all integers are
numeric but all numerics are not
integers so let's check that so if I do
a is numeric on i1 which was assigned as
dot integer 10 that shows me true if I
say is dot integer on i1 so was that an
integer and if I look at the value it
shows me true
now let's look at the character values
so if we say C1 C2 and look at the class
of this it shows me it is of character
type similarly on C2 and you can always
validate that by using the character
function
you can also use some inbuilt functions
such as converting to an uppercase or
getting a substring from the starting
till the position what you would want
the elements I can do a paste function
which basically will give me the data
combined or you can say concatenated you
can also use a paste 0 which we know
will get rid of the space
and it just concatenates them without a
space I can also use a specific
separator which we have seen examples
and we can do that and what we can also
do is we can replace set of characters
so here I am saying
substitute and then if I look at the
values it has basically replaced Rob
with Sena
and let's look at the length of it or
number of characters in this so these
are some basic operations what you are
doing on matrices on your data frames on
your lists and also on your variables
where either you are assigning them
values of a particular type or you are
changing the data types you can also go
for coercion in case of vectors we have
seen that where if you are passing in
values of different types that's coerced
into same types
so later we can learn more on functions
and flow control and how that is handled
in r
let's learn how R can be used to take
care of flow control that is if I would
want to have a if else condition and if
I would want to compute or if I would
want to check some values how R can be
used so here if statement consists of a
Boolean expression which is followed by
one or more statements so we can just
say if we can pass in a Boolean
expression where we would want to
compare particular value or we would
want to check a particular value and
then whatever is passed in the statement
will get executed so what we can do is
here we can use assignment operator I
can pass a value to X now we can always
do a type of and that can tell me that X
is basically an integer and now I can
use my if where I can say
is
Dot and then I can choose integer
and I would want to check the value of x
if that is an integer then I will just
use
brackets and I'll pass a statement here
so let me say print and let's say x is
an integer
and we can execute this and this tells
me that the Boolean value is true now if
for example we would have done something
else or say for example
instead of integer if I had used let's
say character for that matter
and we can check the value and we can do
this so
here we will check the values and it
says
there is an error with the bracket and
let's check this one so if x because we
missed a bracket here so let's do that
one
and then try this and it doesn't show me
any result so how could we handle
something like this if the Boolean
expression does not match to true and in
that case we can always go for else
statement so we can check for a value so
if the Boolean expression is true
statement will be executed and if it is
false then next statement will be
executed so we could have done the same
thing here where I said print X is an
integer which we know is not true and
what I could do is I can here after this
one
say else and then I can open up one more
bracket and then I can say print and I
will say X is not a character
and now we know that X is not a
character so this is a simple way where
you can use if else and you can control
the Flow by passing in the conditions
now that's when you are using IF else
statements now what about while loop so
that also can be useful when you are
programming in R so an else statement is
executed when the condition in the if
statement results to false so that
basically means what we can do here is
let's pass in a word or a set of words
like this for example let's say V and
then we use C function to create a
vector for example and then I can just
say hello world
and if you look at V you can look at the
class of V
it's of characters and if you look at
type of V
it is having the objects or elements as
character now what we can do is we can
basically then say count
and let's assign this a value to
now what we would want to check is is
the count of elements in our V equals to
2. so what I can do is while
my count is less than
say five now I am saying
I would want to do something while the
count is less than 5. so we have already
given a value to count as 2 and now what
I can do is here I can open up a bracket
I can say print and then pass the value
of v and then what we do is not only
this we will also increment the value of
count and we will say count plus 1 and
here it gives me error probably because
we have missed a bracket so let's see
what we are missing out here so let's
just check this one again
so here it is we have created V which
has two elements
of the type character and then what we
do is we assign count a value of 2 and
we would want to check while the count
value is less than 5 we would want to
print the value of V so what we are
doing here is we are saying while then
you pass in an expression which will
check the value of count we do a print
and then we increment the value of count
now this is a simple example where you
are using while to basically test an
expression and while that expression is
true you would be doing something
whatever is passed within your brackets
now we could also be going for for Loop
now for Loop is basically used to
iterate over a list of elements or a
range of numbers so for example if I
have a vector like fruit which has some
values I could just say for I in Fruit I
would want to print something so let's
try this also as an example to test our
for Loop now we can just say names and
we can basically then assign values to
this so let's say VJ
AJ
DJ and let's say SJ and let's create
this let's look at the value of names
now what I can do is I can use it for
Loop and I can say for I
in my names so I will say for I in names
now what do you want to do so open up
your brackets here
and then we would want to say print I
and then basically close the bracket so
you see for every element in this Vector
it is basically going to print the name
one by one so your iterating through
a set of objects by using a for Loop now
this is how we can work on for Loop so
if else while and for Loop can be very
useful when you would want to iterate or
when you would want to check the value
of an expression or when you would want
to Loop and do a particular task
it's always good to to understand how
you manage flow control in r that is
either when you're working with your for
Loops your while Loops also
understanding how you can use your
logical operators for working with your
data in R so let's look at some examples
and understand logical operations
so either you could be having and or you
could be doing it or where you are
evaluating one condition or you are
using not so these are your logical
operations now here I can assign a value
to X and then I can check if my x value
is less than 10 and it shows me false
so I have been checking the value of x
so let's see is it greater than 10 and
that's true now I can use logical
operations here so I can say
and so I'm saying is my x value less
than 20
and is my x value greater than 10 now
both these conditions are not true so in
this case we get the result as false but
if I say x is greater than 20 which is
true and
I am saying X is greater than 5 that's
also true and X is equal to 25 now
whenever we are talking about and we
have to look at all the conditions have
to be right so let's look at this and we
get the value as true but if I say x is
greater than 10 or X is later than 5
then one of the condition has to be true
which is true in our case so we get the
result as true
we can take a different example we can
say is X less than 20 which is not true
but is x equals to 30 and that's also
not true so in this case we get result
as false now we can straight away
compare some numbers and we can say is
12 equals 3 and that's false and if I
say not then that basically will give me
the result as true
so these are some simple logical
operations which help you when you're
working with your data in R now we can
create a data frame by using an inbuilt
data set empty cars and let's look at
our data frame so that shows us the
values with all the different car models
and the different column names so car
models are the row names and then you
have other things like mileage and
cylinder and so on which are the
specification for the data now what I
can do is I can filter out values here
using indexing so I can say data frame
now in that data frame
I would want to compare the value of
mileage which is greater than or equal
to 30 and then I can end it with comma
so that gives me the value wherever the
mileage is greater than 30. I can also
do a subset on data frame where I can
select a particular value
so we can be doing this or we can be
using
square brackets we can also do a dollar
and compare the values now we will use
our logical operations knowledge here so
we will work on data frame where I am
interested in the mileage which is
greater than 20 and
I am looking at the column HP horsepower
and that should be greater than 100
remember when we are doing a and both
the conditions have to be met as true
and that shows me the result where you
are looking at the mileage and you're
looking at the horsepower column both of
these are met and that's why we get the
result
so these are some simple examples of
using your logical operations either
when you're working on a data frame so
same thing can be done on a matrix same
thing can be done on a list or a vector
or individual values now let's also
learn about flow control that is how if
else or else if is handled in R so you
can do a single condition check so for
example I assign a value to hot which is
false
and I'm saying temperature is 50. now
what I would want to check is if the
temperature value is greater than 60
which in our case will not be true
which will not be true because
temperature has been assigned 50 so is
it greater than 60 no
so if I do this
if condition and I am saying if the
condition is true then I would want to
assign the value of hot to true and now
if you look at the value of hot it is
still false why because the condition
which we passed for R if is not true
it has not been met so whatever was
passed within the statement has not been
done
now let's change the value of
temperature as 100 and now if we do the
same thing we say is my temperature
greater than 60 which is right so then
whatever is passed in the bracket will
be applied so what will be assign new
value and now if you see the hot values
set to true so this is a simple single
condition check what you are doing now
certain times there can be multiple
conditions to check and that's where we
use else so in this case we go for
assigning a value to score which is 63
so let's do that and now let's say is my
score value greater than 80 which is not
true so whatever is passed in here
which is print it's a good score will
not be done but it will jump to else and
then whatever we have passed in else
will be done so it will say it's not a
good score so let's do this if
and it says it's not a good score so
this is a simple way of using IF else
where you are taking two conditions or
you are checking the condition but what
if the condition is not met then your
control is passed to your next statement
now I can also do a else if so I can say
score is 63 and I can say is my score
greater than 80 that's my first
condition so it would print good score
but might be I would want to check
something else so I'll say else if and
I'll say is my scroll greater than 60
yeah and is it less than 80 remember the
and which has to evaluate and true for
both the conditions so I'll say print
decent score
I can still keep on giving conditions
here in else if score less than 60 and
score is greater than 33 that would not
meet so that will be ignored
and then you have else which says print
poor so first it checks or evaluates for
the condition which you have passed for
if if that doesn't work then it goes to
else if and if anything in lzf is met
then it's going to take that
into consideration and it will not go
for else if if an else if conditions are
not met then it goes to else and we see
decent score already printed here now
that's a simple example of if else and
if else if wherein we are evaluating a
condition but probably we have multiple
other things to check
now how do you work with while Loops in
R that's very simple so what we can do
is we can assign a value to X and now I
will say while my X is less than 10 so
I'm going to create a loop so I have
said my X has been assigned a value of 0
and that's fine so this is going to be
less than 10 but if we are going to just
do this then it will keep running and it
will get into an infinite Loop so we'll
see how we do that so we'll say while X
is less than 10 I would want to
basically have the value of x I would
want to print X is still less than 10
adding 1 to X and what we are doing is
we are incrementing the value of x now
if you do not do this step
then it will get into an infinite Loop
because X will be always less than 10 so
we are incrementing the value of x by 1
and then we are giving a condition so if
at any point of time x is equals to 10 I
would want to say x is equal to 10
terminating the loop and then basically
my while loop ends so we can do this so
let's say x is 0 and then do this while
loop and now you see
it is at every step it is basically
printing out the value of x it is still
less than 10 adding 1 to X and it also
gives you
the value of x so when we do a x is
currently and I print out the value of x
so it shows me 0 next time you increment
it it becomes 1 and 2 and so on so this
is where you are using a while loop
where you are looping where based on a
particular condition
and then you basically have
once the condition is met you are able
to
complete the loop
now let's look at
let me take this one here we'll look
into functions in a later stage so let
me take this function and let's get rid
of this one I would also want to talk on
break statements in while loop and once
we are done with the flow control and
while Loops then we can look at the
functions aspect either we can look at
how we control our functions or how we
create built-in functions so let's look
at this one and let's continue with our
while loop
so we just saw a simple while loop here
and what we also want to see is when you
are working with your while loop how do
you break if a particular condition is
met
so we saw a simple example of while loop
and that's fine wherein we were printing
out something we were Auto incrementing
the value of x we were also checking at
one point of time within our while loop
if the value of x was met
we would say we are terminating the loop
and it comes out of that
now if that does not happen then we
continue doing it how about a break
statement so break statement is when you
would want to end the while loop if a
particular condition is met so for
example here I assign a value to X which
is 0 now I want to evaluate this lesser
than 5 so that means I will be Auto
incrementing the value of x so I'll
create my while loop I'll give in a
condition that X is less than 5 now what
I want to do is I want to use the cat
function which will print the value so I
am saying X is currently and I am
printing out the value of x then I say
print X is less than 5 because we have
not yet incremented the value of x we
are adding 1 to X like what we saw in
previous example I am saying X is then
incremented by 1 and here I am saying if
x reaches 5 so while we keep
incrementing the values within the file
Loop we'll see if X's value is 5 we will
print it is equal to Phi and we can just
do a break now if you do not use a break
you can still end the while loop but
break is basically to end this Loop here
based on condition which is met and we
can do this and then run this while loop
so you see here x was met as Phi and we
just broke out of the loop so that's
your simple while Loops what we are
seeing is similarly we can work on for
Loops so for Loops can also be useful so
your conditionals what we saw as if else
or else if your while loop is while a
condition is not yet met you keep
looping and keep doing some actions now
what you can do is you can also work on
for Loops so here I am creating a vector
and then I am going to Loop that is I am
going to iterate through every element
so I'll say for
and when you're using for Loops you'll
say four and then you can given anything
you can given any value I can say I I
can say x so I'm just giving temporary
variable in vector and then I am
printing it out so this basically prints
all the values one by one so there is
one more way to do it you can say four
and you can say I in
and I would want to take length of the
vector
so 1 2 the length of vector that is till
the last element is reached I would want
to print
the vector elements using the value of I
so what is I here it's the index
position and I can do it in this way
so if you are looping over a list
so I'm creating a list and it's very
simple so you can just do a for Loop
where you can say for I in list I want
to print the I and that gives me the
list elements or you say for I in and
you give from starting position that is
1 till the length of list and you would
want to print every element so here we
can also use double brackets
so if you would want to Loop through a
matrix so sometimes that might be
required so let's create a matrix which
has 1 to 25 values around by row and you
look at your Matrix and now what you
want to do is you want to iterate
through a matrix so you want to do a
looping so I'll say 4 I in Matrix I
would want to print out the values and
that prints out all the values in Matrix
now what if I want to print the square
in square roots of numbers between 1 to
25 so I can say for I wherein the value
starts with 1 ends with 25 and then
within my for loop I can basically give
this condition where I am saying get me
the square root that is I into I or get
me a square root of I and just print it
out so I'm saying message I is this one
square root is this and
my square is this n square root is this
so if I look at this values
here
now I am looking at all the values from
1 is to 25 I am looking at the square of
the values and I'm looking at the square
root so what we did was we did a 4
we passed in the elements by saying I in
1 to 25 and within the bracket I have
said what do I want to do for every
element so either I have calculated a
square I have calculated a square root
and then I am printing out when I am
using the message function which takes
the value which you are passing in comma
the value of I similarly square and
similarly square root so these are some
simple examples of understanding flow
control in r that is using your for
Loops your while loops and also your if
else later we will spend time in
learning about functions which could be
either created by the user or built-in
functions and also factors in r
welcome to this section of our
programming where we will learn about
functions whether that is about inbuilt
function or creating your own functions
and working on your different data
structures
so what are functions function is
basically a set of statements to perform
a specific task now R has a large number
of inbuilt functions so you can say
packages which you can import and start
using
or users can create their own functions
so when it comes to functions the syntax
is very simple you give a function name
you can assign your function to a
variable and a function can take no
arguments one argument or any number of
arguments so let's see some example on
functions so for example here we are
creating a variable called squares and
we are assigning a function to it now
this function would take one argument
which is a and then we use a for Loop so
we say for I in from 1 to the number a
we would basically be doing a
exponential computation so what we would
do is we would Square the value
in this particular range and assign that
to B and print it now when we do this
we can call in this function and pass in
a value to look at the square of that
particular value now this is a simple
example of function so this is how it
would look depending on what value you
have passed to the function so for
example we say squares and we pass in a
value of 4 so that becomes for I in 1 to
so you would start with one
the value of 1 square would be 1 and
then you have your value for 2 so 2
square would be 4
then we have 3 3 squared would be 9 and
then we have 4 squared which is 16. this
is a simple example of function and this
is how you can create your own function
to calculate or carry out some
computations
now let's look at some other examples
before we get into built-in functions
which basically allows you to work with
different data structures
so there are different mathematical
functions which can be used for your
data science or computations
you have your regular Expressions which
can be used for pattern matching
or you can also use functions for data
manipulation now before we get into Data
manipulation let's look at how you work
with functions taking some examples so
let me bring up my R Studio
wherein we will try out some examples
and see how functions work now here are
some examples and we can see how this
work let me just clean up
the console and we can start here now
here we are creating a simple function
which does not take any argument
we call it as hello world and this will
start with the word function
and parenthesis now that could have
arguments passed in however this
function we are not passing in any
argument
and what we are doing here is we are
printing out whatever value is passed
within the bracket so let me just do a
control enter my function is created and
you can straight away call this by just
doing this now however if you would have
tried this function without the bracket
for example something like this then it
would have printed out the complete
function it would have printed out the
complete function and whatever you
passed in to hello world but if you
would want to call the function then
basically you would just do hello world
and then use the brackets so that's how
you call the function and that's how it
shows the result now your function can
be with a single argument so for example
here we are passing in an argument
called name and we can then use this to
pass a value to this so here I'm saying
hello name
I have my function but this one takes a
single argument and we are going to use
paste which basically can concatenate or
just add some whatever you are passing
in to paste so we will say paste hello
and then the name notice that I have
given a space here
after hello so that I can have it in the
right format and I can just do this so
the function is created and now let's
pass a name here and just try to call
the function so name is one argument or
a single argument which is passed to
this function so let's look at the
result and that shows me the name
whichever was passed to this one
now what we can also have is function
created which takes two arguments and
this is a simple example so here we are
creating a function add num I'm saying
function it takes to argument I'm not
providing any value or default values
for this we'll see some other examples
for those now here this particular
function takes two arguments and
whatever you pass in here a addition of
that will be seen
so let's create this function and let's
call it and test it and that shows me
the result as 70
now what we can also do is we can add a
vector to a number so Vector is list of
elements or list of objects you can say
and here we would want to perform add
num or we would have to call add num
function by passing in Vector which
becomes the first argument and the
second value is the next argument so
let's run this one and that shows me the
result wherein 5 as a value has been
added to every element of this
particular Vector now when it comes to
function you can also have default
argument values which can be passed so
here let's look at as an example so we
have hello name again but this time
instead of passing in just an argument
we will also provide it a value or you
could say that could be considered as a
default value now
when we create this function we are
doing the same thing as previous
examples but we are passing in an
argument and that argument has a value
now once I do this I can surely call
this function without passing in a value
and that shows me the name which we had
assigned to the argument or we can even
pass in a new name which will be
assigned to name so if we do this it
works in both the ways fine so this is
in one way you are passing in a default
value and then basically you can either
call the argument or
you can assign it a new value
so if we would do something like this
hello name and then for example I would
say name equals say
Jerry and if I would do this so that
also works fine however since we are
passing in an argument we are assigning
a value so either we can let it go for
the default or we can just pass in the
value or we can be very specific in
mentioning the argument and then the
value for it
now how do we return value from a
function let's look at this so here we
are creating a function we are calling
it full name
and this one takes name
wherein we are giving Sachin and title
is say Tendulkar and what we would do is
we would use a return statement here so
return would basically
use the paste function it will take the
values of name and title and then glue
them together however we are using also
a space so that there is a space between
these two values to the arguments which
are passed now if I run this argument
sorry this function my function is
created now we have already passed named
arguments or we have already passed
value to those so we can straight away
say just call the function and that does
whatever you have mentioned in the
function body
I could have also said that I could
create a new one wherein I will pass new
set of values which we saw in a previous
example and then if we call this it
takes up the new values so either you
can let it go for default like what we
did here we can also pass in new values
or if you would want to keep it specific
you could basically say full
underscore name
that's my function I could say name
equals and I can say John
and then I will say title
Smith
and that's also fine so we can do this
and that works in the same way as it
would have worked with
just passing in the names
so this is fine and if you would want to
test it out say for example if I would
just take off name here and just do this
that also works perfectly fine wherein
we are
still using these arguments in the
particular order now if I would have
changed this one to name
wherein I am already passing in a value
for name and if I try this so in this
case what happens is name is Smith and
basically your title becomes John
right so we have to remember how we are
what arguments we are passing and if we
are basically
assigning values to the arguments or
letting it pick up the default ones
so let's do this and that looks okay now
when you talk about scope of a variable
okay now before we understand scope of a
variable let me show you some more
examples on function now say for example
if you were using built-in functions we
have lots and lots of built-in functions
which are available for programmers
which they can use in their data science
activities or data processing or
computation now here we are using a
function called R Norm to generate 1000
random values from a normal distribution
of mean 0 and 1. so I would use the r
Norm that's an inbuilt function and I
will call this say normal distribution
so that is already done now we can find
out the mean on these random values
which would have been generated using
the inbuilt mean function and that works
perfectly fine you can also create a
histogram out of this and if I do this
it shows me the histogram so let's see
the histogram here
let's bring it out and that shows me the
histogram of normal distribution if you
would be interested in knowing about a
particular inbuilt function you can just
do a question mark and use the function
and that basically shows you the
documentation of the function so this is
a generic function which computes a
histogram of a given data value and here
it takes arguments so this is basically
your data this could be the number of
arguments which you are passing in for
your histogram to be created now we can
look at some more examples here so I can
say two histogram with large number of
interval breaks and this is where I am
also specifying breaks and passing in a
value so this allows me to provide
arguments or functions by position
now the same example which we have given
here we can do it without breaks
argument but as a good practice we
should actually give name to the
arguments which we are defining so if I
would do this
wherein I'm passing in my data that is
normal distribution and then for breaks
I'm just giving the value 50 and that is
also fine it works perfectly fine here
now we can create our own function which
as we saw in some basic examples
functions which can be without arguments
say this is a simple example or with
arguments
so this one we have already seen how you
can create a function without giving any
argument or by giving an argument and
then basically calling in the function
now when it comes to optional arguments
so we can look at this function wherein
I would want to say find out the
exponential value of a particular number
so I call it Expo value
I use my function I say this will take
the value X now that's an argument which
we are passing in we could have given it
a value or we will just let the user
provide the value when this function is
being called I will also give a default
argument which is power equals to and
here we would want to get a histogram of
the values
with a particular power so if I create
this particular function
that's done and now I will just pass in
my value I don't need to mention power
that has been given a default value yeah
if we would want to change it then we
can pass in that so let's run this one
and that gives me
exponential value a histogram based on
the normal distribution data and by
default
it is using power S2
now what we could have also done is we
could have specifically mentioned a
different value for power
and that works perfectly fine I could
have just passed in the value s power
and that also works fine
so here you are using named arguments
and
basically
passing in any other arguments
now what we can also do is we can use
these named arguments and then we can
also do or we can pass these arguments
that is what we call as passing any
other arguments now if you look at the
explanation of this
hist function histogram function
if we look at this it shows me these
three dots and this is what we can use
to pass in any other arguments so let's
look at an example for this one
so say for example I would want
to create a function where I am passing
named arguments I am passing in the data
but then I would also want to pass any
other arguments which can be passed
dynamically now for that we can create a
function here
wherein I am calling it Expo value again
I am passing in my X which will be the
data which we will pass in
you are mentioning power which is 2
which is a named argument which can also
be considered as a default or you can
change the value or you can provide a
new value and then I am also giving
these three dots which are also passed
in within this particular function so
let me create this function here
now once that is done then I can call
this function by passing in my data
which is normal distribution power is 2
and then I'm also using these breaks for
getting my histogram with intervals
of 50 so let's call this function and
that gives me the histogram now what we
can also do is sometimes it might be
useful to pass logical arguments so for
logical arguments what we can do is we
can create a function which will take
the data
here I'm using a named argument exp that
is for exponential I am saying if the
value of
histogram is false and then I am also
giving any other arguments so what we'll
do here is in this function we will say
if the value of hist is true then this
block of code will get executed where
you will get a histogram based on the
exponential which has been assigned in
the function passed as an argument
and if that doesn't hold true which is
by default false as we have given in our
function then this piece of code will
get executed so let's create this
function and that's done and now we can
straight away just pass in our data
exponential value is given as two
histogram has been given in false that
means the else part of the code will get
executed and we can look at the values
here I can also say
histogram is true and that's where we
will be calling in the hist function and
I can do this that shows me the
histogram so in this way we can pass in
named arguments we can pass logicals and
then we can also pass any other
Arguments for our use case
now looking further in functions let's
also understand the scope of a variable
in a function so here I am saying V and
then I am saying
I am Global variable let's create this
and then I am saying stuff so I am
Global stuff so this is basically we
have assigned some values to variables V
and stuff now let's create a function
where I'll say fun
I'll use the function and I will say
this will take my variable stuff
I'm saying print V
and then for stuff I'm assigning in a
new value and then I'll print stuff
so let me create this function and let's
see how it works so if for example I
would just say print V that shows me
the global variable which we had created
earlier and since I'm using that within
my function it basically has the value
now I also have a global stuff so I'm
saying print stuff and that shows me
whatever was assigned to the variable
and now we will basically call the
function by giving in the argument as
stuff the variable which we had created
now if we do this then it says
reassigning stuff inside the function
and that's because within the function
we are basically assigning a new value
to this stuff now I can also just do a
print stuff now
if and if you see it still goes back and
prints the
Global variable so only within the
function
reassignment happened and that's what we
understand when we talk about global
variable or local variable now
to create a function to find the final
output amount to be paid by a customer
after adding 20 tax to the purchased
amount how do we do that so I am here
creating a function which will take X as
and what does that function do we would
want to basically
find out
the amount which is paid by customer
after adding 20 percent of tax now how
do we calculate that so we take X plus
20 percent of X and that would be the
final amount which will be paid so we do
a return t
and this is my function so let's create
this function and then let's pass in a
value to see what is the amount which
customer would pay
with an addition of 20 tax so this is a
simple function where we are passing in
one argument we are giving it a value
and then we are doing computation within
the function body
what we can also do is we can create a
function where I am passing in an
argument and I can then check the value
of that so if the argument passed was
greater than 0 then we would find out
the final amount which is amount plus 20
percent of the amount
if the amount is less than or equal to
amount then equal to 0 then our final
amount is equal to amount and we return
F amount so here we will be evaluating
these conditions and based on that my
function will return the value so let's
create this function and pass in a value
and that shows me 100 so you can just
test this by saying amount 1 and say for
example I would have passed in 0 now in
this case my final amount is 0 because
there is no amount which needs to be
paid by the customer now checking the
argument and the body of a function so
we can always use this inbuilt function
args which will tell me
for this particular function what are
the arguments and what is the body of
the argument which basically tells me
whatever we have coded within the
function body
now to understand the scope we can
create a function here which is taking
an argument X and what does this do so
we assign a value to y
then we basically say G1 and here I am
using function of X now what is that
function of X do
so this one will take the value of y
plus multiply X by itself
so this is
a function which we are creating
and then I am saying G1 of X so what you
are doing is whatever value was passed
in as X
for that function X will be applied so
let's create this function and then pass
in a value 10 and that gives me the
result as 110.
similarly we can create another function
where we want to do some computation and
then I am creating one more variable
which has basically the function
pass in a value for y and then basically
what you do is
you are calling in your G2 function and
then let's call in this function so
let's do this
and
let's also create F2
and then finally we will call in F2
which is internally calling G2
so these are some simple examples where
you are doing some computations and
creating some simple functions let's
also create a function which is taking
two arguments so here I have G2 function
takes two arguments X and Y what does
that function do here we are saying y
plus X into X that's my G2
and similarly I'll create F2 which is
going to have a value assigned to y
and this one is going to call in my G2
function
which will take
X and Y
X which we are passing in here and Y
which we have assigned
so let's create this
and then let's call our F2
and what does that have to do it
basically has the value of y assigned
and then it does whatever is mentioned
in G2 with our X and Y values so I am
passing in 10 here
so it is basically Y which is 10 plus
you have
the x value which has been passed here
so let's look at the calculation which
is 10
so that gives me 110 so 10 into
10 into 10 plus the value of y
so this is how we can create functions
which have been assigned some values and
then pass in some other values to those
to get some more examples here when it
when we work with functions and see how
we can use functions to carry out our
basic operations or calculations so for
example here I am creating a function
and this will take an argument wherein
we are saying it would be marks
now let's do this and the function body
would say result is not defined now if
the marks are greater than 50 then
result will be
pass and you will have the message which
is your result is
and then you are passing in the value of
result
so let's look at this one so let's
create this function pretty simple
function and then let's pass in a value
here so I'll say status as 60 which will
be checked for the value greater than
marks or lesser than marks and that
tells me your result is pass and if we
give this one then it says your result
is not defined however we can have
additional statements here which can say
if the result was lesser than 50 then
what should have been printed this is a
simple example let's look at one more
example and here my argument is H now
just notice that we are not passing any
default values or we are not passing any
values to the arguments we are just
passing in an argument which will be
assigned a value when you call the
function now here we say age group is
not defined we say vote is not defined
and then we start using some condition
checks so I say if the age passed is
greater than 18 then the age group would
be adult and the person can vote
and message your age group is and voting
status is will be printed out so we can
use this or from our previous learning
we can do a if else and modify the
function
so let's create this function and then
pass in a simple value to this and that
tells me what is your age group and what
is your status to vote
so now if we would want to create a
function to convert a name into
uppercase let's see how we can do that
so we are creating a function here which
takes the value name
now then we also find out the length of
this particular argument and for that we
are using a inbuilt function called n
character which will be for your name
and you would want to find out the
length of this particular name and we
would say if the length is greater than
5 then we are again using a inbuilt
function call to Upper which will
convert the argument or the name passed
to uppercase we will say message
user given name is and then you print
out your name so let's call in this
function
so let me first create this and then I
can call in this function and we clearly
see that the number of characters in
this world is more than five and that's
why it is converted to uppercase however
if you would call the function with a
name which has less than five characters
it says as it is
now this is again a simple function
which we created let's see how you can
create a function to calculate bonus
now here we are passing in two arguments
so this function takes two arguments one
is salary
and one is experience and then we say if
the experience is greater than 5 then
bonus percentage will be 10
and else bonus percentage will be five
and here we will calculate the bonus so
first it will find out
how many years of experience a
particular employee has and based on
that a value of bonus will be assigned
or bonus percentage will be assigned and
then you say what will be the bonus that
is salary into the bonus percentage
and return the bonus amount so this is a
simple function let's basically
select this
and let's create this function and then
let's calculate the function if the
salary is 25 000 and experiences 6 years
and that basically will tell me the
value so let's look at the value it
tells me
2500 which is 10 percent of the salary
similarly if we go for this one which
will
basically go for the execution of else
part of the code we can do this and that
gives me bonuses half of it
now
how do we handle multiple conditions and
multiple actions so let's look at that
so let's create a function which takes
one argument which is age
we would check if the age is greater
than 0 then we would want a nested if
within this condition
so if age is greater than 0 then
whatever we have given here will get
executed
and this will be this part of your code
and here I am again checking if age is
less than 18 then
age group would be kids else
if now else if you take the second
condition so if the age was passed if it
is greater than 0 then we get into this
block of the code now it was greater
than zero but then is it less than 18
then I would categorize the person as
kids
if Edge is less than 60
then we will say age group adult
else we will say age group senior now we
can basically say that we could have
given more conditions to this because
here we are saying if age group is less
than 18 then the individual would be
within the age group of kids if that is
not true that is is not less than 18 so
probably it is 18 or greater than 18
then we are checking the second
condition if the age is less than 60 age
group is adult and if
these two conditions are not met then it
jumps to else where age group is senior
and if this whole block
was ignored because age was less than
zero then we would have just printed out
age group is not defined matches
messages wrong H and your age is such
and such so this is our whole function
so let's go ahead and run this
now let's check the age group when the
age is 10.
when the age is 40 when the age is 65 or
when the age is minus 10 which is not
defined now there are some inbuilt
functions which can be used in r
such as your switch function so looking
at this function that is switch function
we can see
or we can use this for our different
kind of operations so here your switch
function returns values
match with the first argument and first
argument should be a character let's
have a look at the example so say for
example you want to return the house
rent allowance or HRA amount based on
cities
so we create a function called HRA now
that takes an argument which is city
name and here we will say what does this
function do so here I am saying HRA
amount and I am going to use the switch
function now switch function I am saying
I would want to convert the city name to
uppercase so that we can maintain some
consistency and here I am saying if the
city is Bangalore it would be 7500 if it
is Mumbai thousand if it is Delhi 8000
Chennai 7500
and you have 5000 value and you are
returning the HRA amount now what do we
do with that so let's
create this function
it's done and now we will pass in the
value so we will see
whatever value has been passed to this
and that gives me the value here right
so switch is basically taking me
directly to this value now however if I
try to provide a city name which is not
given in the list
so when I am saying say for example Pune
now what is happening is it is just
taking a value which has not been
assigned to any of these conditions
if I go for again something else which
is
in a lower case now this is where your
two upper function will come into use
and if we do this it basically converts
this into uppercase Mangalore and then
basically it gives you the value so this
is the usage of a switch function
let's look at one more example so for
example here we are creating a salary
range which will take an argument which
will be banned and I will say these are
my bands or you can say these are my
options so I can say L1 is basically ten
thousand to fifteen thousand L2 is so
and so and L3 is so and so and you
return the range now
let's create this function
sometimes you have to do it this way
so our function is created and now we
can just do a salary range given a value
and that gives me the range of the
values however if you pass something
which is not mentioned then it basically
prints out null
so in R you can also use repeat which
can be useful and
what does repeat do so here I am
assigning a value to a variable called
time let's do that and then I'm giving a
piece of code with repeat now what does
repeat do so you are passing in a
message which is hello welcome to our
tutorial and then you are saying if time
is greater than or equal to 20 you would
want to break out from this Loop and
then you also increment the times value
and this will keep repeating till this
if condition is met
wherein we have said time value starts
from 15. so let's do this and this
basically will print out the message
wherein first my time was 15
which was less than 20 so you increment
it it becomes 16 you print it again 17
print it again 18 print it again 19 and
20 and as soon as you reach the times
value which is 20 it breaks out of this
and it stops printing this particular
message
okay now let's look at
some more examples so if you say r
we will use say a function to find the
square of Any Given user number okay if
the Square value is less than 100 then
increment user value by 1 and find
square again and repeat this till Square
exceeds
100. pretty simple so you create a
function which takes n as an argument
and you would want to repeat it so you
would want to repeat this by squaring
the numbers
until the square
exceeds hundred and once it reaches 100
you will break out
so this is what we are doing and we are
Auto incrementing or incrementing the
value of n by 1 every time we calculate
a square
and then you return the value of n so
let's create this function
and now let's calculate it for square 6
and that tells me what is the square now
as soon as your Square value touches 100
it basically breaks out of the loop
now if you would want to find balance in
a bank account after n years
if
a person has deposited x amount in the
beginning and Bank gives a interest of
eight percent per annum right this is a
simple calculation so it needs the
amount which was deposited you need the
year and you need the rate now ER which
is n years can be given by the user rate
we have already given eight percent
however functions main functionality is
that you can even assign new values to
it say later one month down the line the
bank rate changes might be it increases
might be decreases then function should
not be modified it can just take up the
new values and start calculating from
there on now here
we will say
get the final balance function takes
amount
the amount which would be deposited here
and that could be say four years or five
years or ten years for which you would
want to calculate the rate of interest
and add it to the amount
so I'll say for I in 1 to year so that
depends on how many times you would want
to run this loop I would say interest
would be using the round function I am
saying amount into rate whatever is the
rate of interest
and then you are giving two years
now final amount
will be calculated
so you are basically saying amount plus
interest and you will pass in a message
where we'll say ear is the value of I
that's first year or second year amount
what is the amount what is the interest
you are calculating based on the round
function and final amount will be amount
plus the interest
and then you basically say
amount will be given or final amount
will be assigned to amount now if this
is a function you would want to return
the final amount so let's select this
and then basically create a function and
let's say I would want
the final balance if the amount
deposited was 5000 it was kept in the
bank for five years and rate of interest
was eight
now that should basically give me my
final amount
and if we
double that
so we say amount is 10 000 number of
years is 10 but the rate of interest is
less so let's calculate this and that
gives me the interest however if you
notice based on my message it is
basically telling me what was the first
amount what was the interest what was
the final amount and it does that
for all these number of years
so these are some simple examples for
your functions right now we can also
look at on the similar lines we can
create some interesting functions so you
can find the total number of years
required to raise
thousand dollars if the user deposits
750 per month so here you're not
actually calculating the final amount
but
you would want to find out how many
years are required to basically have the
amount as eight thousand so your
function we are saying the amount
is say 550 or say 750
per month
now I would say let the final amount be
0 as of now month is 0 and I will say
while my final amount is less than or
equal to 8 000 I would want to do
something
and that is you are
incrementing the value of month by one
because that's your first time your
amount is less than 8 000 whatever
deposit was made say 750 per month
and then you have final amount which is
your initial amount which has been
assigned to F amount that is 0 plus the
amount
you print out the message and then you
basically say year
is
whatever value was passed for month
so you may want to have it for number of
years or years with particular amount of
month so we will calculate the year
value now here what we are doing is we
are calling in this required yes
function without an argument which takes
the default argument
or you can pass it with 750
we can run this so let's create this
function pretty simple
done and if we do not pass an argument
then the amount is 750 and it tells me
what would be or how much time it would
take for us to reach from say 750 or 550
to
final amount
similarly if I would have done this
it tells me again a new value so we are
finding out the total number of years
required to raise
thousand or raise the amount to 1800
dollars so these are some simple
examples of functions which you can use
for your operations your calculations
and also creating functions which can be
repeatedly used with
either one either no or either multiple
arguments now so far we were learning on
creating our own functions and we also
looked at using some inbuilt functions
either creating a plot or basically
doing some basic operations or passing
in multiple arguments
so let's look at some more examples and
when we talk about built-in functions
there are lots and lots of built-in
functions which are available in R which
can be used so let's look at these
so for example here are some built-in
functions
which can allow you to work with
different data structures for example
you have a sequence function which
allows you to create sequences so for
example I could just say test nums and I
can just say sequence and here I can say
where does it start from so might be I
can say 0 goes all the way to 50 and
then I can also say if I would want a
jump or how many numbers should be used
so for example let's do this and now if
I look at test nums
so that shows me the value however not
too confused we could have also done
this using assignment operator like this
and then look at your test nums so it
tells me
it has created a list of numbers from 0
to 50 which are even numbers now you can
always do a class of
and let's look at this
and that tells me the objects here are
numeric and say for example
I would use type of
to see what is this test nums which we
just created there was a typing mistake
let's check this and it has the values
with W right so we have created a
sequence here where we are creating a
list of numbers which have
a space of two or you are saying about
even numbers now you can also use a sort
function so I can do a sorting here and
I can give it an increasing or a
decreasing order so if for example I
have created this sequence and I could
just create a simple variable like this
pass in a vector into this which could
be say for example I'll try your test
nums
and then look at your V so those are my
numbers and you can straight away do a
sort on your test nums so I could just
do a sort on V and that basically shows
me the number however I could also do a
sort V and then I could say
here
let's check this V comma
and then you can say decreasing equals
true
and let's do this it just reverse or
puts the data in a reverse order or it
sorts based on decreasing value and
having the greater value in the
beginning and the lowest value at the
end
so you can use a inbuilt sort function
similarly you can use a reverse now
reverse need not actually sort the
values it will just reverse the elements
in your sequence for example let's say
V2 and I will again use
this one as C and then just passed your
test nums that's an easier way or I
could have created a new Vector so I'll
say test nums that's my V2 and you can
do a reverse
on V2
and that basically shows me the values
but here we see
let's see so we are looking at
okay so this was wrong I should have
given a capitals and do it yeah this is
fine
and we get the values however if I had
created something like this V3
and let's say C and then let's say 99
and 2 and 3 and 4 and 5 and 78 100 so
that's a vector I'm creating
and now what I can do is I can use the
reverse on
V3
and you see it has just reversed the
elements in the list
now we could have done this without
giving these brackets here and it shows
me the result so this is good to
understand what you are sorting this
sorting is basically going to look at
the objects and it's going to sort them
in ascending or descending order reverse
is just going to
reverse the elements in your list now
similarly you can also use append which
is basically to combine objects so let's
say V4 and that will basically have
append
and let's say let's take V2
and let's take V3 and this is what we
would want to append and now look at
your value of V4
which basically has everything added
into one so this is your append
similarly you have other functions like
finding out the absolute value of a
number you would want to find out the
square root you would want to find the
sum of all the elements in a vector you
would want to find out the floor value
exponential value of something
and you basically finding out the mean
value so these are some built-in
mathematical functions so you have built
in simple functions your mathematical
functions you have regular expressions
in R which can also be used for pattern
matching now what we can simply do is we
can
create a variable let's say text
sorry for caps let's say text and here I
will pass in something R is a
programming language
for data science
let's do this and now I would want to
use grep function so I can say crap and
this one needs what I am searching for
so let's say language and where am I
searching for so I am searching it in
text and let's do that and that tells me
where is this found so when I do a grep
I am trying to find out if this was
found in my element so here I am saying
text and grab language similarly I can
also use one more function which is
finding out index positions so I can
also find out index positions
by basically giving the vector and here
I can do a grip pass in my Vector a b c
d you are searching for B and in your
vector and that tells you your B is at
the index position 2 D is at the index
position 4. so here we are using some
regular Expressions now there are also
other ways in which R can be used for
data manipulation so let's learn about
factors in R and how do you work with
factors and what are they for
so when you talk about factors so here
let's clean this up
and let's see what is this so when you
say factors
here we are talking about categorical
variables
so categorical variables can take only
limited number of different values now
don't be confused with this histogram
example here
might be we can just look at packages so
that that doesn't get confused
so when we talk about categorical
variables
we are talking about variables which can
belong to only categories for example in
R there is a data structure to work with
these kind of variables and that is
called your Factor
so with factors we can be sure that all
statistical modeling techniques will
handle such data correctly so for
example you can talk about a person's
blood group and you can say
the blood group could be a or b or a b
or o so say we collected information
about eight people and we
recorded this information as a vector
and we can call it blood group so let's
do that so let me
try that here
so if I say blood group
and then I would like to create a vector
here so that
we can look at information about eight
people and their blood group and this
can be
in the form of a vector which can then
be created or converted into Factor by
using the factor function
so how do we do that let's say I have
blood group and here I will basically
given some values so I will use C
function and here let's give some values
so for example let's say B
let's say a b
and let's say o and let's say a again
let's again say o
might be one more o
let's say a
and let's say B so here we have eight
entries and let's consider we have
recorded the blood group of eight people
and this is in the form of a vector so
for example let me create this now this
is a vector which we have created and
you can always look at the value of this
one so let's say
blood group
and that basically
okay there was a spelling mistake let's
do blood group and that basically shows
me the values and here you see all the
values that are in double quotes now we
have basically created a vector now to
convert this Vector into Factor we can
use the factor function
and how we can do that is basically we
can say for example
let's go here and let's say blood
group
underscore Factor
and for to convert this Vector into
factor I will use the factor function
and then basically pass my
blood group here
and now I have created a factor and we
can look at this Factor by just doing in
blood group factor and now if you see it
basically shows us a factor it does not
have any double quotes and you can also
see the factor levels for categorical
variables which get printed out here now
what what actually R is doing here is
first R scans through Vector to see the
different categories in there
then our sorts levels alphabetically
and then it converts the character
vector
to a vector of integer values
so these integers correspond to set of
character values
to use when factor is displayed now we
can always do a structure
to find out more details of this
and here I will pass in blood group
factor and let's look at this one and
this one shows me this factor is with
four levels so inspecting the structure
will reveal that it has four levels it
shows me what are the categorical
variables and it shows me some integers
so here we are dealing with a factor of
four levels now A's are recorded and a
would have say
recorded as one so that would be a first
level
you have a B's which which are recorded
here
and that is basically your second level
B is the third level and O is the fourth
level so when this uh when we are
looking at this Factor we may think why
this conversion so categories could be
very long character strings and each
time repeating a string or an
observation can take up a lot of memory
so using factors and having these levels
can reduce the memory space now factors
are actually integer vectors and each
integer corresponds to a category or a
level
now to specify a different order of
levels we can specify levels inside the
factor function how do we do that so
let's say I will say blood underscore
Factor 2
and here I will basically give the same
so I'll say Factor
and this Factor will have blood group
which we had created earlier but this
time also I am going to specify levels
and then I can basically pass in a
vector here so within this levels I will
specify the values what are the levels
so here I will say oh then I'll say a
then let's say B
and then let's say maybe
so this is what we are doing here
to specify different order of levels and
we are specifying the levels here now if
I do this that would have got created
and let's look at blood
Factor 2 and that shows me the value
here below where you have specifically
assigned the levels now if you look at
the previous one where we had blood
group Factor where levels were
automatically understood by R so we were
looking at the categorical variables we
were seeing what are the levels here and
here what we have done is we have just
created again a factor but then we have
specified levels in a different order
and you can obviously do a structure on
this to compare so for example I'll say
structure and then I will say blood
Factor 2 and that basically shows me the
structure with four levels so this was
the initial one where we said a a b b
and 0 and then there were some integer
values which were responding to these
categorical variables here we have given
a different level and we have a
different set of numbers which we see
here
so if we compare structure of blood
factor and blood Factor 2 we will see
encoding is different right now that is
done we can also specify the level names
so what we can do is
as we use names function for name of
vectors we can pass vectors to levels
here and there is basically
a function what you can use so let's say
I will
say levels
and then within this I'll pass blood
underscore Factor
or blood group underscore Factor here
so once this is done let's say blood
group
so in this one we created blood group
underscore factor and this one was blood
Factor two so that's okay I mean it's
just a naming convention and here let's
pass in levels
to my blood factor and then what I can
do is I can pass in the values here
so this is
when you would want to give specific
names and let's create a vector and
let's call it say BT underscore a
and might be you would want to give PT
underscore a b
and then you will give BT underscore B
and the final one is BT underscore o
so what I'm doing is I'm doing the
naming for these particular categorical
variables by using levels
now let's do this
and it says blood Factor not found so we
have to look which one did we have so we
have blood group Factor so this is what
we should have given so let's say blood
group Factor
blood group factor and now we have given
some names here so let's look at
the blood group Factor now
blood group underscore factor and now if
you see we have some levels or we have
given the name to the categorical
variable so if you compare this one so
here we were creating a blood group
where we had these variables
and these variables what are the
categorical variables
which was just creating a vector then we
created a factor out of it and then we
looked at our Factor we looked at the
structure of it and similarly what we
did was we created a different Factor so
let me also change the name here and let
me call it blood group Factor 2 but here
we were specifying levels in a different
order
let's look at this one so which is blood
group Factor 2
and then you can look at the structure
of this one
blood group Factor 2 and here in this
example what we did was the initial
blood group Factor what we had created
we have just given some names to that
like what we would do in case of vector
by using the names function here you are
using the levels function so we
basically created some levels and let's
group at the blood group Factor now
which basically has some different names
so what we are doing here is we are just
using naming now we can also specify the
categorical variable names or Levels by
specifying label arguments so inside the
factor function
so that is basically to give some names
or levels
so let's look at this one and how do we
do that so we can specify by using
Factor
which basically creates your Factor
and then here I'll say blood group
I'm going to specify labels for my
naming so
in
previous examples we saw how we were
using the levels right and this was
by specifying levels for a different
ordering
and then we could have also done this by
saying levels and given some different
names or we can just do labels and then
within this I will say labels equals
and then I can say c
and then let's give these values which
we have PT underscore a b t underscore a
b b t underscore B and O so let me just
copy this one again
and let's put it here
and then we can basically do a control
enter so I would have created a factor
here
and then
we should remember one thing here that
it is important to follow and the same
order as the order of factor levels that
is a a b b or o now these are the levels
what we are seeing so if you look at any
one of these in the beginning which we
had created it was showing me what
levels it has a a b b and O
and a a b b and O so we are following
the same order but we are using the
labels Within
my Factor creation Now sometimes there
might be issues because of wrong
ordering so we can actually use a
combination of manually specifying the
levels and label arguments when creating
a factor
now what we can do there is we can say
factor and in this case let's say blood
group
which I am creating then I will
basically say
levels
to give
the right ordering and here in levels
let's say o
let's say a
let's say B
and then let's say a b
so this is for my levels which I'm
creating and then what I can also do is
I can go for labels
so levels will take care of my ordering
and labels will take care of by naming
the categories so let's say labels and
then we can create a vector
and we can give some names so we can say
BT underscore o
what else we have we have BT underscore
a
we can then say BT underscore B
and finally we can say BT
underscore
a b
and then let's create this one
so now what we have done is we have
created a blood group which has levels
which is following your ordering which
is following the naming as we have
passed so if you look at the levels it
tells you the names what you have
created it also tells you all the
categorical variables which were used
for my blood group and basically these
will have some labels so
we can anytime
look at our
blood
Group which we had created in the
beginning
and let's look at the values of those so
when we talk about categorical variables
there are two kinds in categorical
variables so you have nominal or you
have ordinal now in nominal you don't
have any implied order for example blood
group O is not necessarily greater than
a that is O is no or not more worth than
a
that we can think of now trying such
comparisons with factors will generate a
warning so say for example we would want
to look into our blurred
factor and let's look at
what blood group Factor contains now
that's the new blood group Factor let's
say blood group
factor and here I will try to pull out a
value here and let's compare this with
blood
factor and let's look at some other
value now in this case we see not
meaningful for factors so it cannot
really compare the categorical variables
and see if one variable is greater than
other or has more worth
now
uh there can be many examples where such
ordering does exist and in R we can
impose such ordering in factors thus
making it ordered Factor so inside
Factor
began set the argument ordered is true
and we can do that now for example you
would look at the size of a dress so
let's say dress size
and here I will say for example let's
create a vector
and let's say medium
let's say large
let's say small
let's say again small
and then let's say large
let's say medium
again an entry of large
and then let's say medium
so here I am creating a vector
and let's see if we missed out any
quotes or comma so it says unexpected
symbol
and where is that so let's look at this
one so we have dress size
and we are looking at C so I am saying m
l s s l and here is a quote missing and
that was the reason so
this one also has a code missing and now
it should resolve yeah
so let's look at this one and now we
have created a vector called rest size
now obviously you can create a factor of
this so I'll say dress size underscore
Factor where I would want to look at the
ordering of this so let's create a
factor and in Factor we will pass our
Vector on which we we want to convert or
we want to create a factor we will say
ordered
equals true
so I am specifying a particular ordering
and then I can also specify levels as we
saw earlier so in levels we will give
the category so what categories we have
so we have small we have medium and we
have large so these are the three levels
which we have and let's create this as a
factor now that's done and what you can
do is you can look at the
factor and we can also do a comparison
so let's for example look at our Factor
what does it contain it has some levels
and if you closely notice there are
these levels which also have a
comparison of which one is worth or more
worth than other variable so you can
look at dress size factor which has some
ordering which we have implemented and
now let's do a comparison between dress
size and
compare it with some other variable and
see what is the result so now it says if
it is true or if it is false earlier we
were not able to do that because we did
not have any ordering and if we were
looking at the variables we were not
really clear if one variable has more
worth than others so these are some
simple examples what we have seen now we
can also look at some more examples so
say for example I do a type here
now that basically is creating a vector
if I would want to compare the element
that is Type 3
is it greater than Type 4 it shows me
false right now here what we are seeing
is
that if you are looking at a particular
value okay we can basically see that
there is some comparison Happening Here
If I compare this with 1 and 2 which
tells me true or false and if I look at
this it also does some comparison so I
can always
convert this into Factor by using the
factor function so I can do this
if I'm checking if for example I would
want to create a nominal factor I can do
a type dot factor and it tells me it is
true you can also do a type dot Factor 2
and then use the factor function pass in
your type which is a vector and here you
are saying ordered as true which we just
now saw and now you look at type dot
Factor 2 which is creating an ordinal
type of variables now here we can again
create type dot factor three so what we
are doing here in this case
we had a vector we basically said type
dot Factor
we said factors of true
and then we looked at the nominal Factor
we also did a factor 2
and then we created Factor but we
specify ordered as true so we get
ordinal
and now if you look at type dot factor
three here you are saying ordered and
you are also specifying levels like what
we did in the previous example and now
you would look at ordered factor with
user given order which also has the
levels which clearly show us a
comparison between those now we can take
a different example we can say type dot
factor four
we are using the factor function I am
specifying type which is a vector I am
saying ordered is T I'm using level
which is giving me uh some levels
and then we also have labels which are
basically going to have the naming
convention so let's look at this one and
look at type dot factor four so it tells
me what are the categorical variables
which are small medium large small large
medium these are for my type values
which we created a vector here these are
my type values for which we created a
vector we said ordered is true the
levels is small medium large and we gave
some names so we are looking at the
values of this so This basically helps
you to work on your categorical
variables when you can then compare the
values and you can see what does it show
now here what we are doing is we are
creating a different Vector we say small
tall tallest medium small and so on
let's look at this one which is
basically type and it has the value so
what we would want to do is we would
want to compare height type of first
value with the fourth value
so for that let's create a vector
on this type ordered is true level is we
are saying
small medium tall and tallest
these are the levels and now when you
look at your type dot Factor Phi it
basically shows me what are the levels
which you have specified so small is the
smallest then you have medium which is
bigger than small tall is bigger than
medium tallest is bigger than tall but
we have assigned some levels and based
on these levels now you can compare your
values in this Factor type dot Factor 5
take the first value which is small and
compare it with the fourth value which
is medium and you will know if small is
greater than medium so the result would
be false now I can also convert this
into integer and I can continue working
on this now here you have
basically a sequence
so let's use the sequence function where
I am starting from 0 ending to 20 and
there is a jump of 2 so that basically
creates a vector let's look at the
vector value here and if you would want
to sort the vector so we are using a
inbuilt function wherein let's create
this Vector with these numbers I can do
a sorting I can also do a sorting with
decreasing is true
you can do a reversing a vector so these
are some examples of inbuilt functions
which we have already discussed so here
you are doing a reverse you are finding
out the structure you want to append to
vectors you want to check the class of
an object you want to convert a vector
into a list using as dot list
converting the vector into a matrix
you are having a sample
with with two random values between 10
and 20 so these are some inbuilt
functions which we have already
discussed such as your absolute such as
your
vector and getting an absolute value or
getting a sum of it or a mean of it
around
or basically rounding into two decimal
places getting the ceiling value getting
the floor value truncating it get
returning the log getting the
exponential value and so on now we have
also looked at regular Expressions
earlier so regular Expressions let's
just revisit that so here you are
basically creating a variable called
text and then you can just do a grip you
can say what you would want to search
and where you would want to search it
and that would give you the logical
value indicating if the pattern was
found you can try to search something
else which might not be found you can
also search for independent values like
this and that basically can give you the
position of that particular object
within the vector
and here is one more example of working
with timestamps so for example if I
would just do assist dot date it Returns
the current system date if I would want
to
set that as a variable and then call
that variable it shows me our current
time
I can also use as date and then let's
look at this one so as date and this
would be converted into date and then
you can obviously use formatting
techniques like
getting the month getting the day
getting the year so here we are passing
in the date and then we are saying what
format we would be interested in and
that basically gives us the data in a
particular format so that's also useful
when you have your time series data or
when you would want to convert the data
types and so on now there are different
ways in which you can do formatting so
for example in this one we were saying
month day and year I can also say
for getting the full month name or
getting the full year name I can do this
caps so I can look at this one and that
basically shows me my date in a
particular format so these are some
inbuilt functions which we are seeing
and before this we were seeing factors
which is mainly to work with categorical
variables either they have levels Auto
assigned and they might not have labels
so you can give labels you can give
levels you can control the ordering you
can give levels in a different way so
that you can have a different ordering
so this is how you use factors and work
on categorical variables maybe that is
nominal or ordinal and easily you can
do your statistical computations on such
data let's learn about data manipulation
in R and here we will learn about
d-plier package and when we talk about
this D player package it is much faster
and much easier to read than base R so D
player package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt or data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package deployer by just
calling in library function and this can
be used for grouping by data summarizing
the data adding new variables selecting
different set of columns filtering our
data sets sorting it selecting it
arranging it or even mutating that is
basically creating new columns using
functions on existing variables so let's
see how we work with d player now here I
can basically get the package here so I
can just say install dot packagesdp
player now we already see the the
package here which is showing up so I
will just select this one I can do a
control enter and that will basically
set up the package package deployer
successfully unpacked so that is done
now you can start using this package by
just doing a library D player and this
was built it shows me my version of R so
let's also use a inbuilt data set that
is New York flights 13 so we can do
install.packages and that will search
and get that relevant data set
I can again Call It by using Library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a tabular format
which shows me year month day departure
time schedule departure time and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data which can help us in
understanding the data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here it shows me how
many variables we have so this is fine
now we can start using deployer and in
that we can use say filter function if
we would want to look in for specific
value now here we have the column as
month so I will do a filter now I'm
creating a variable F1 I'm using the
filter function on flights which we
already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically look at the month where the
month value is 0 7 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on F1
which shows me the data wherein you have
filtered out all the data based on month
being seven
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say F2 filter flights and here we will
say month is equal to 7 Days 3 and then
look at the value of F2 if you are
interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month 7 and days
three you could also look into a more
readable format by using view on F2 and
that gives me my selected result so we
are just extracting in some specific
value we can keep extending this so here
we can say flights is what we would want
to work on I'm using the filter function
so I can straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view I can also do a view in
this way I can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this I am
saying filter I would want to look at
the flights month being 0 9 day being 2
and origin being LGA and then that shows
me the value here and obviously you can
scroll and look at all the columns and
if you see the origin column it shows
the selected value so now we have
filtered out our data based on values in
three different columns now what we can
also do is we can use and or we can use
or operators so I could have done this
in a a little different way so I could
have said head which shows me initial
result I will do a flight So within my
head function I am passing in this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flight's data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we're given a value and I'll
say and and I'll again say flights
wherein I will select the day being two
and and remember when you talk about and
it is going to check if all the values
are met true so then you say flights
origin LGA and you look at the value so
in this way I can filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific in specifying all the columns
it makes the code more readable so let's
look at the values and here you are
looking at head which shows me based on
month day and then you can look for
further columns for other variables that
is origin being LGA now what we can also
do is we can do some slicing here to
select rows by particular position so I
can say slice and I would want to look
at rows 1 to 5 and I can do this so you
can always assign or look at the view of
this I can just do here so when I did a
slide one is to 5 it shows me my entries
for one to five now similarly we can do
is slice 5 to 10 and now you are looking
at 5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set and then you would
want to add it to your existing data
frame or you would want to add a new
column so this is where you use mutate
which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate so it's pretty simple so you
create a variable over delay now I would
want to do a mutate so that it adds a
new column so I'm selecting my data
which is flights I will call the new
column as overall delay and then
basically
I can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure DeLay So let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view and you could have just look at
flights if you would want to compare so
you can look at the flights and this one
would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here and if you
do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 columns so we know
that the new column has been added
to
this overall DeLay So if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do an overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay
the computation remains same but at this
time if I look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure now you can
also use summarize and summarize
basically helps us in getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a summarize
and what we can do is we can look at our
data and we can say on what basis we
would want to summarize this particular
data so we can do a summarize function
now summarize on flights I will say
average airtime and I would want to
calculate an average so for that I'm
using inbuilt function called mean I
will do that on airtime column
so let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what I'll do
is I will use the summarize function I
will say average airtime and this one I
will look at mean of a time so let's see
if there is a a Time column I might be
let's look at this one and I will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at summarizing based on
airtime not the arrival time so air time
is how much time it takes in air for
this particular flight and we will want
to use the trans summarize function not
the transmute so summarize flights
average airtime and this one we will
calculate the mean of average airtime
and I will also do a n a removal which
is I am saying true so let's do this and
that basically shows me the average
airtime is 151 I can also do a total a
time where I am doing a summation of
values or I can get the standard
deviation or I can basically get
multiple values such as mean
I can say total air time where I am
doing a summation and then I can look at
other values which is if you would want
to put in standard deviation here you
could do that so let's look at the
result of this summarize and this
basically allows me to get some useful
information which is summarized based on
a particular function such as mean sum
standard deviation or
all three of them now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function so we can always
use the group by Clause now here we are
taking a different data set so we will
say for example let's look at head of Mt
cars and that is basically my data set
on empty cars now that shows me the
model of the car it shows me mileage
cylinder power this and your horsepower
and various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set so
here we can say let's do a grouping by
care so there is a column called gear so
I will call it by gear I will look at my
data set and then what I'm using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol is called
piping so that basically feeds your
previous data frame into next one so
this is sometimes useful and you can get
this by just saying Ctrl shift and M and
you can then use this so we are going to
have piping so I am saying empty cars
now this is my original data set where I
did a head or I could have done a view
on this one if you would want to see it
in a more readable format and that
basically shows me the data so we are
using a different data set so I want to
group it by the gear column so I'm going
to call it by gear and this one takes my
data that is empty cars I'm using the
piping and then I am saying group the
data based on gear column that's done
now let's look at the value of by gear
or you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a internal object where your
data is grouped based on a particular
column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you your data
grouped based on a particular column now
I can again use the summarize function
where I would want to Now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so I'm doing a summarize and here I
am going to say Gear 1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column and then I'm saying Gear 2
which is mean well you could give some
meaningful names to this and let's look
at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is sum and mean values
based on the gear
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear and I'm
again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear we had
grouped the data and we called it by
gear so we took our original data set Mt
cars but now within this particular data
which was grouped by gear I will take
this data set I will use the piping and
I will summarize it where I am saying
within this particular data set I would
want to get the sum or I would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values so what you are doing is you
are either looking at your original data
set or you are looking at the data which
was already grouped and then you can
look at the values now here what we can
do is we can Group by cylinder say might
be you are interested in looking at data
which is summarized based on the
cylinder column you can do that and then
for this buy cylinder I am doing a
piping where I am using the summarize
function and summarizing will then be
done based on the mean values of the
gear column or the horsepower so let's
do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample underscore n
function and Sample underscore
fraction for creating samples so for
this let's take the flights data set
again and we would want to get 15 random
values now that is done and it shows me
15 rows with some random values from the
data what you can also do is you can do
a portion of data by using sample
underscore fraction and here I'll say
flights I'll say 0.4 which will return
40 percent of the total data so this can
be useful when you are building your
machine learning where you would want to
split your data into training and test
might be you are interested in some
portion of the data so you can do this
which is very useful function and then
you can look at the value of that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use a range which is a
convenient way of sorting then your base
are sorting so for a range function
let's do a view based on a range so we
will work on the flights data set which
we have and here what we would want to
do is we would want to arrange the
flights data set which is based on year
and departure time and we are doing a
view out of it so that basically gives
me the data which is arranged based on
your year and departure time now I can
do a head to give me some highlighting
of that data now the piping operator
what we are using
can be used in these ways also so here I
will say DF I will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
DF which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are creating a variable called result
here now that has the arrange function
so what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so I would want to sort
the data but what data would I sort so I
will use sample n which will give me
some portion of the data or some sample
data now what is that sample data so
here we are using nestling that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here now this filter will work on
DF
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20 I will
say size is 5 and I would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so I am using the disk on this
particular mileage column by default it
is always ascending so let's get the
result out of this
which will basically show me the mileage
details in a descending order so this is
my data frame and now we can look at the
result what we have created
so just do a view or do a head and look
at the view so here you see mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have not
only used an inbuilt function we have
not only arranged the data that is we
have sorted the data but we have sorted
the data based on a descending order on
a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20 and we
have also said we just need five random
samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi assignment so
I can say filter
wherein I am going to use DF which was
assigned Mt cars I am going to say
mileage should be greater than 20 then I
say B which is going to get a sample out
of a and I just want five random values
so let's look at that so we have B which
is
going to get a
set of five values from a now I will
create a result variable which will
arrange B which is sample data in a
descending order now let's look at the
result of this and that basically shows
me what we were seeing earlier so you
can do a multi assignment where you can
create a variable get a sample out of it
and then basically whatever is that
result you can arrange that or sort that
in a descending or by default ascending
order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator so piping so here I will say
result I am passing in my DF that's the
data set I'm using piping and which
basically tells what you need to do on
this particular data set so I'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then I'm going to push
that or forward it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it and then basically you can
look at the result so these are some
simple examples where you can use your D
plier with multiple assignments or using
your nesting to filter out the data you
can also do a arrange which is to sort
the data you can get some random samples
out of it you can summarize the data you
can also summarize the data based on one
or two or multiple columns and you can
use some inbuilt functions to summarize
the data based on some functions which
are applied on the variables or on the
columns
you can transmute it where you would be
interested in only looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or to filter out the
data so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example DF where I have my data
let's look at this one and if I just do
a DF at this point it shows me my data
set and if you would be interested only
in particular column then your D player
also allows you to either we can do a
filter or we can simply do a select now
for selecting we can choose
our data so for example I'll say DF
underscore I'm interested in mileage I'm
interested in Horsepower might be I am
interested in your cylinders in this and
for this one what I can do is when I
would want to do a select I can
basically say
selected DF let's call it some name I
can say control shift M which is for
piping and then basically what you can
do is you can do a select and you can
choose your columns so I was interested
in mileage I was interested in
horsepower
I was interested in cylinder and here
what I'm doing is I'm using a select
where I can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and I'm sorry here we will have to give
it TF this is where you are passing in
your data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a DF or head on DF
underscore mileage horsepower cylinder
and look at the selected result so you
can be looking at selective columns I
could have done this filter but filter
will always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than four or something else but
when you do a select you are selecting
specific columns so view always gives
you all the columns head gives you
highlight but then select can be useful
when we are interested in looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use the player for manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tider and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation done
using your tider package let's learn
about that IDR package which makes it
easy to tidy your data and this
basically helps you creating a more
cleaner data so which is easy to
visualize and model now this comes with
mainly four functions so you have gather
which makes your data wide or it makes
wide data longer so that is basically
used to stack up multiple columns you
have spread function which makes long
data wider that is stacking the data
together or stack if you would want to
unstack the data to data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes and then your spread can
spread the data across multiple columns
you have separate which is function with
splits single column into multiple
columns and to complement that you have
one more function which is unite and
that combines multiple columns into
single columns so these are four main
functions which are used in your tider
package so let's look how we work with
this so let me bring up my R Studio here
now for this first is let me just clean
up my screen here doing a control l so I
will install the package it is already
installed but we can just do a control
enter and then
I can say do you want to restart R prior
to reinstall Store install I'll say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package did tidyr the rest
idrs has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package using our library
function
and that was built under R version 3.6
now I can basically start using these
functions so for example here we are
creating a data frame so let's say n is
and then we basically would say we will
call it white now that's the variable
name I'm using the data dot frame
function I am saying ID which will be 1
to n so that will take the values from 1
to 10 and then these are the values
which have
10 entries so this is a vector Phase 1
phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it now that's done we
can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the ID column and it has phase dot 1
phase.2 and phase.3 now we can use our
function so for example we can work with
gather that is reshaping the data from
wide format to Long format and basically
you can say stacking up multiple columns
so let's see how we do that here I'll
call it long I am working on White I am
using the piping
functionality and then I'm using gather
so this one I will say what will be the
data which I will use so we are using
wide as a data frame
then I am saying response time so that
will be basically one more column and
then you have your columns which you
would want to
basically stack so I'm saying from Phase
1 to phase three so let's do this and
once this is done let's have a look at
our variable long so this one shows me
that I have an ID column
I have the response time column and I
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have phase.1 phase dot
two and phase.3 so I have all the
columns are being stacked here so all my
data so now I have totally 30 entries in
this one so this is basically using your
gather function now sometimes we may
want to use a separate function now
separate function is basically splitting
a single column into multiple columns so
which we would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in as the columns we
selected then I am saying separate I
want the face column and then I would
say when I separate the columns what are
my column names now I could all also
give a separator by giving a comma and
then mentioning the separator if that is
required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the column which we used so we were
doing a face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
Target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
Target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use a
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here we will call
it long Unite and we will take long
separate which was separating the data
we want to unite so we will take phase
Target number and we want to have a
separator between them so let's
basically do this and now let's look at
the result of this unite so you see you
have the face and Target merge together
so you have phase dot one the separator
is dot as we have mentioned and we have
United multiple columns so this is one
more function of your tider which helps
you basically tidy up your data or put
it in a particular way now then you have
your spread function and this is
basically for unstacking so that is if
you have if you would want to convert a
stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so it will take two columns say
key in value and spread it into multiple
columns so it makes long data wider so
we can look at this one we will say long
unite I'm using the piping I will use
the spread function I'll work on the
face column and response time and let's
do this and then let's do a view on this
so it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning so
these are four functions which are very
helpful when we work with tider package
so let's learn about visualization
and here we will learn about R which can
be used for your visualization now one
thing which we need to understand is
because of our ability to see patterns
which is highly developed we can
understand the data better if we can
visualize it so the efficient way or
effective way to understand what is in
our data or what we have understood in
our data we should or we can use
graphical displays that is your data
visualization so there are actually two
types of data visualizations so you have
exploratory data visualization which
helps us to understand the data and then
you have explanatory visualization which
helps us to share our understanding with
others so when you talk about r r
provides various tools and packages to
create data visualizations
and which can be used for both kind of
data analysis or both kind of
visualizations so when you talk about
exploratory data and visualization the
key is to keep all the potentially
relevant details together
now the objective when we talk about
exploratory data analysis is to help you
see what is in your data and the main
question is how much details can we
interpret
now when you talk about different
functions which we see here such as plot
which is more for a generic uh plotting
you have bar plot which is used to plot
data using rectangular bar so you can
say creating bar charts you have
histogram or hist function to create
histograms where you look at the
frequency
of the data or basically used to look at
the central tendency of the data you
have box plot which is used to represent
data in the form of quartiles you have
GG plot which is a package which enables
a user to create sophisticated
visualizations with the little code
using the grammar of graphics and then
you have plotly or plot l y it creates
interactive web-based graphs via the
open source JavaScript graphing library
now before we see some examples here
let's also talk about when you talk
about plotting let's also try to
understand what kind of plots you can
have and what kind of techniques you
have so let me open up my R Studio here
now for example I can pull out a
particular data set and let's look at
this one so here I can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information now what I can do is I can
install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then I
can simply do a plot wherein I am doing
a plot on chickway data set so let's see
what does that show it summarizes the
relationship between four variables in
chickweight data frame which is in our
built-in data set package now from these
plots we can see for example weight very
systematically over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets now
when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some editorial decisions what
features we would want to highlight for
emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated right so there are different
ways of doing it now when you talk about
your graphics or visualizations you have
I would say three different types or you
can say four so you have the base
Graphics which is easiest to learn now
here we are having an example of Base
Graphics where I can use the base
Graphics I can get a
data set using Library
then I can simply create using plot
function to take generate a simple
scatter plot of calories with sugar from
us serial data frame in the mass package
and then I can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of Base
Graphics now you also have what we call
as grid Graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools
now you also have latest Graphics which
is general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your GG plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid Graphics so you
have different ways now here since I
already have used library and I have the
data set I can just do a x so I can
assign the sugar related values to X and
calories related value to Y then I can
use one more which is Library function
and calling in Grid now I can basically
use functions such as push viewport if I
would want to create a plot using your
grid Graphics to create the similar kind
of plot which we created using base
Graphics but this will give you much
more power than base Graphics it will
have a steep learning curve but it is
usually useful so I can do this where
I'm saying push view port then I can
basically say I would want to have a
data viewport I would say different
functions of your grid package so I'm
saying rectangle you have x axis y-axis
given some points here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can basically create a
simple grid Graphics based plot here now
there are different other options which
we can use to create plots now before we
go into understanding how you create
plots let me just give you a brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used so here we will
look at these different plots now for
example we have a bar chart which is a
graph which shows comparisons across
discrete categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared and y-axis
which represents a measured value and
height of the bars are proportional to
measured values Now to create different
kind of charts you can use ggplot which
is a package for creating graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits and that is a part
of Tidy worse ecosystem so it takes each
component of graph accesses you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects and you can build graphs on
particular data you can modify each of
those components in a way that's more
flexible and user friendly you can if
you are not providing details for the
components then TG plot will use
sensible defaults and this basically
makes it a powerful and flexible tool
now here
are different options when you use your
GG plot such as you can use geom or what
we call as geometric objects to form the
basis of different type of graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have Scatter Plots that is underscore
point you have underscore box plot for
box plots you have quartile for
continuous X violin for richer display
of distribution and Jitter for small
data so here is some simple example
where I would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one where we are using
Library function to get the ggplot2
package then basically we would want to
look into the mileage data we would want
to look at the structure of it and then
we can basically get the Tidy verse
package finally we can create a bar
chart using 0 underscore bar
and we can basically also mention what
would be in x axis now you can also give
different colors to basically add more
meaning to your data you could also go
for stacked bar charts so here we are
actually telling GG plot to map the data
in the drive column to fill the
aesthetic so here I am giving
aesthetic access class and I am saying
what is the data we need to have and
then we are using geom underscore bar so
you can also have dodged bar
in your ggplot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using your
position as position underscore Dodge
okay now you can obviously use your
different packages which are inbuilt and
you can create your bar charts and you
have other kind of graphs such as line
graph which is basically a type of graph
that displays information as a series of
data points connected by straight line
segments such as this one and for this
one we are using if you see jio
underscore line now you can also create
a scatter plot which is a two
dimensional data visualization that uses
points to graph the values of two
different variables one in an x-axis one
on y-axis like what we saw in base
Graphics example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship or lack
of relationship between two variables
and you also have histogram which I
mentioned is mainly to look at the
distribution of a data to look at the
central tendency of the data basically
looking at your large amount of data or
for a single variable you would be
interested in saying where is more data
found in terms of frequency whereas
lesser data found in the graph how close
the data is towards its mid point or
what we call as mean median mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins so these are some Basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of Base Graphics or grid
Graphics now here let's do an example of
pie chart for different products and
units sold so you want to create a graph
for this first let's create a vector and
pass in the value here now I can also
create labels which I would want to
assign to these values and then
basically I can plot the chart by saying
Pi so that's the kind of chart which I
would want to create and I would say the
data would be X and labels so let's do
this and that shows me a simple pie
chart now I can also give main details
here so instead of just doing a pi x
comma labels I can say what is the main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a simple uh plot now I can also find out
what is the percentage and then
basically I would be interested in
plotting the pie chart which takes X
which takes the labels which will be the
percentage which we are calculating here
by doing a round function and then you
can basically give details to your graph
you can say what color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be in your chart
what are the values and then basically
fill up the colors so let's run this one
and that shows me the percentage which
was calculated and it gives me the
details and we can always have a look at
our plot now if you would want to go for
a 3D pie chart then you can get the
package which is plotrix let's use that
by calling in the library function let's
pass in some data to X and let's give
some values or labels which will make
more meaning to the data and then let's
plot the 3D graph so I'm saying Pi 3D
here where I'm using X and labels
then I'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like and basically give the
values so it also takes the title when
you say Main and by chart of countries
now let's create data for graph so again
we are having a variable here we have
created using the C function creating a
vector and then let's create a histogram
for this one
where I would say xlab what would be
your data around x-axis what is the
color what is the border and here I'm
creating a simple histogram
which as I discussed earlier will always
show your values on the x-axis and y
axis is more of frequency and then you
can look at the set of values and what
is their frequency and we can basically
use this histogram for exploratory data
analysis look at the data try to
understand what is the central tendency
of your data values now we can also give
some limits by using the X Lim and Y Lim
and then I can also specify what is the
limit so we have given some values here
wherein we have said your X limit is 0
to 40 and Y limit is 0 to 5. now if you
compare this with the previous one which
we had created this one based on the
frequency had taken the limits but we
can assign limits explicitly by giving
this and then create a histogram which
makes more meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality let's view this to see what
does that data contain so you have ozone
solar wind temperature month and the day
so this is the kind of information we
have in the air quality now let's use
the plot function to draw a scatter plot
where as I mentioned you would be
interested in analyzing variables and
see what is the relationship between
them so to plot a graph between ozone
and wind values so we will say plot we
will say the data which is air quality
from that I would be interested in the
ozone column or ozone field and the wind
field I can create a plot based on this
now I can also be saying what should be
the color what is the type of the data
which you would want to create and you
can look at the info information so you
can create a histogram you can create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for tick weight where
we did a base Graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone and then
that's your ozone concentration you have
your ylab which is the number of
instances you have what is the title
ozone levels in New York City what is
the color so these are the details what
we have given with our plot function and
let's look at the data so it just tells
me that this is the ozone concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data now we
could also create a histogram by picking
up a particular column that is such as
solar from your air quality and that
basically shows me the frequency of
solar values and we can then try to find
out what is the made what is the mean
what is the standard deviation and so on
you can also look at your histogram and
try to understand if it is left skewed
and right skewed so we can do that now
here let's get the temperature out from
this particular data set let's create a
histogram on temperature and that
basically shows me the frequency of the
temperature values and what values have
the most frequency or most occurrence
now you can create a histogram with
labels
so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with non-uniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then
passing in your temperature you can say
what will be the main what is the title
what will be your x-lab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color what is the Border
what are the breaks you would want to
have for your bars and you can simply
create a histogram using this so This
basically takes the breaks which we have
given such as 55 to 60 60 to 70 70 to 75
and so on so this is basically creating
a histogram with non-uniform width and
it purely depends on the kind of values
what you have now you can also create a
box plot which sometimes helps us in
understanding the the data quartiles
also understanding our outliers so you
can create multiple box plots based on
the data from air quality so we'll
select all the data and then we'll do
some slicing on the data so let's create
a box plot which tells me the values and
if you look at these points here like
single dots these are basically your
outliers we can learn about that more in
later sections so you can use your
ggplot to library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install.packages and get ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart R and
I can say yes so let it get the package
I think the package was already there
and now
let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that I have the
library function
and let's do a attach where I'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then I will create a variable P1 I
will use ggplot I will pass in my data
I'll give the Aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot to basically create a plot
which gives me the box plot for the
values here and this is based on the
cylinders which is there in your data so
we can always look at what does our data
contain and what kind of values or
features are available in the data now
let's create a box plot we will also use
the coordinate function and that
basically gives me based on the data so
I've changed the coordinates now if you
look at the previous one where we
created a plot we had mileage on the
y-axis and cylinders
on the x-axis
now I did a coordinate flip and that's
like your transpose function so you have
created the box plot but you have just
flipped the coordinates you can create a
box plot and then say fill which is the
factor of cylinder so that can be used
to fill up the values in your box plot
now what we can also do is we can create
factors so we have learned about factors
earlier which is usually used to work on
categorical variables so here let's
create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have am you
have cylinder and if you look at the
factors which we have created we have
passed our data what is the field or the
column we are interested in what is the
level of values there and what are the
labels for those values right so we have
learned about factors you can always
look into the previous section and learn
more about factors now let's create a
scatter plot by using the ggplot
function again we will use the data as
empty cars I will go for mapping option
and then I will give my Aesthetics that
is what would be x what would be your Y
and you also would want to use what kind
of function you are using so let's go
for geompond point and that basically
helps me in creating a scatter plot now
you can create a scatter plot by factors
so here we will say ggplot so notice in
all of these cases depending on the kind
of data you have depending on the kind
of plot you are interested in you will
use the GG plot and then basically a
function with that or the inbuilt
package so here I am saying data is
empty cars I am going for mapping which
basically will take the values for your
X X and Y what is the color and the
coloring will be done based on the
factor values now if you remember
factors will obviously have some levels
and those levels will basically help you
in differentiating between your
categorical variables so I'm saying as
dot Factor on cylinder and then I'm
using geompoint to basically create this
scatter plot so let's do this
and I can look at the values of this one
so it says must be there is an error
which says must at least one color from
the Hue palette so let's look at that
one so the error which we were facing
when we gave color as the factor values
was because when you look at these
factors which were created with some
labels if we look at the values of these
it tells me there are any values in that
particular column similarly your gear or
similarly you can completely look at the
complete data set it tells me cylinder
you have am you have care now these have
some we have created some labels but
these have any values
so what we can do is we can create a
scatter plot as we did earlier by giving
the Aesthetics and that's a simple
scatter plot wherein I'm also using
geompoint so that I can have these
points by default or with defaults you
can also give a color specific basically
if you would want to have different kind
of data in the same plot or I can create
Scatter Plots by different sizes by
giving a size or I can give a color and
size and that's again one way in which
you can create your Scatter Plots now
let's also see how you can visualize one
more data set which is MPG so I can also
do it in this way where I set GG plot 2
and then pass in look at the data set
what we have here you can just do a view
on this to see what my data contains if
the fields have any any values if that's
going to affect your plotting so now
what we can do is we can create a bar
plot or a bar chart so I am saying GG
plot the data would be as we have given
in previous lines that is ggplot2 MPG
then I will say what should be in my
Aesthetics and what kind of
chart are you going to create so I'm
saying geom underscore bar so that's my
bar chart and that has basically your
class and count now you can create a
stacked bar chart where your information
is stacked in the same bars and we are
still using the same data we are going
for Aesthetics which is class and then
when you say geome bar which creates
your stack bar we will use fill which is
Drive
and we can always go back and look at
our data for example you can always look
into this so you have the drive column
here and you are also working on this
complete data set so let's go ahead and
create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked here now you can do a Dodge by
giving the position as Dodge so we are
still going to go for a stack chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful you can use this by using
geompoint where you are mapping and you
are specifying what are your Aesthetics
so we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class and we have different
classes and based on that my points have
been colored now you can also use a plot
lyu or plotly Library so let's install
this one
I will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then I can access that package using
Library function and then create a
variable to which you are assigning your
plot underscore ly plot so data is empty
cars what will be your x-axis what will
be your y-axis and details on your
marker which we have given wherein I
will give a list which is size color
which is a combination and then you have
your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where I'm
going to use plot l y
and let's look at this plot
so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot l y and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data so this
is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or how you can have your
graphics or visualization used to
understand your data obviously there are
much more examples much more ways in
which you can pass into your plot
functions or your ggplot and the inbuilt
packages which are available in R for
your visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis or explanatory
data analysis so try these graphs and
see if you can change these options and
try or create new visualizations
now let's do a Hands-On project to
perform a Time series analysis using our
programming in this project
we'll be using time series energy data
to explore the variations in electricity
demand and renewable energy Supply over
time
over to Ajay now welcome to this session
where we will learn on time series
analysis using our programming language
so this is basically a mini project
where we will look at time series data
and how we can analyze it visualize it
to basically find some important
information or gather insights from the
data now when you talk about time series
analysis time series is basically any
data set where your values are measured
at different points in time so when you
talk about time series data data is
usually uniformly spaced at a specific
frequency for example hourly weather
measurements you have daily counts of
website visits monthly sales total and
so on so when you talk about time series
that can also be irregularly spaced and
sporadic for example timestamp data in
computer systems event log or history of
911 emergency calls now when we work
with time series data for example here I
am taking a energy data set we can see
how techniques such as time based
indexing resampling rolling windows can
help us explore variations in
electricity demand and renewable energy
Supply over time now here we will look
at some aspects of this data set which I
am considering so there is this is open
Power Systems data set and here is the
data set I have we can look at the data
set now this is in a simple format it
has time it basically has values for
consumption and then you have data for
wind and solar and wind plus solar so in
certain cases you have only the date and
the consumption but then if we scroll
down we will also find data for wind
solar wind plus solar and so on so this
is a Time series data set which we would
want to work on sometimes you may also
have the data collected which just does
not have the time but it may also have
time stamp that is it would have say
hour minutes and seconds and that can
also be worked upon so let's consider
this data set and let's work on this
project where we will Analyze This Time
series data set
now here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long term Trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how do wind and solar
power production compare with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find a lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically coal
or you have this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my GitHub
repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I have
given the documentation sample data set
and also you your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your R
studio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work
so first thing is we will create a data
frame
from this data set now here if you see I
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column I
am also giving row dot names and I'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as I showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
have date consumption wind solar wind
plus solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just create this let's look at what does
this data frame contain and here if you
see it shows me some data which has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so I can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data I can also do a tail and look
at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind solar wind dot solar and
that basically has n a values so there
are missing values but let's look at the
tail and that tells me that there is
some data available for wind and solar
and wind solar now we can always look in
a tabular format using View
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see any values but if I
really scroll down
I can see some values which would be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so I can just use view now I can
look at the dimensions of this
particular object
and that tells me there are 400
4384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can be useful but I also look at my
other columns so they are of the num
types so that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if I try to
do this this will show me that this is
null because date as a column does not
exist because we created it as an index
so if I look at Road names
and then I search for my data show me
the index column or row dot names it
tells me these are the values that's the
date column which we are seeing here now
we can access a specific row by just
doing a my data and give the index value
or row name value so let's look at that
and that shows me based on this index
you are looking at the value you can
obviously search for a different date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector and you can give range of
values so that is 0 1 2006 to 4 of
January and we can look at this one so
it shows me
these are the values so here actually
I'm not giving a range but I am just
selecting multiple values from row.names
now we already know that in R you have a
summary function so you can always do a
summary and that gives you for each
column it gives you minimum first
quartile median mean third quartile and
maximum values so we are looking at
consumption we are looking at wind solar
and wind dot solar now this is good but
then if I would want to really visualize
the data access the data do some
analysis then it would be good to take
all the columns and then we can later
decide to change the data type of say
date column if we want to use it so
earlier I was using date as row dot
names or the name of the rows or index
what you call in any other programming
language so here I will just use my data
set and I'll say header as true I'm
calling it my data 2. let's look at the
data and this one shows me
five columns wherein My First Column is
the date consumption wind solar and so
on now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type
so it tells me that if now I'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor with four 384 levels and
these are the values so it is not in a
date time format it's a factor now what
we can do is we can convert this into a
date format how do we do that so let's
have a variable X and I'm going to use
as dot date function and I'm going to
pass in my date column so that's
assigned to X now let's look at the head
of X and it shows me the values we will
also see what kind of class it is and we
will look at the structure of X so class
already says it is date type and look at
the structure so it shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into X now how do I
basically extract values out of it or
make it a part of data frame so first I
will use so all once it has been
converted in date format I will go for
as dot numeric and here I will create a
variable called year and I will just do
a format on X which is basically of date
type and there I'm saying percentage y
so that will get me the year component
out of this let's look at the values
that shows me year component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if I look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what I can do is I can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c byte that is
column bind and I will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me date so
that should be date format consumption
now this one might not be date format
but we'll see you have consumption wind
solar and we have extracted the year
month and day which can help us for
group by we can do some aggregations we
can do a plotting and we can do various
things by these additional columns now
let's look at first three rows here so
I'll say one is to 3 for my data 2 and
that shows me some data here you can
always do a head and look at the sample
of data so that basically shows me month
day your columns and then you have your
date now what we can do is we would want
to visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as I said if we want to visualize the
data say for example I want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here gigawatt
hours so if I would want to create this
visual to basically understand the
pattern of the data how do we do it so
we can you create a line plot of
full-time series of Germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is I can straight away
use the plot method I can then say what
would be in my x-axis what would be on
my y-axis what would be the type of
graph I would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so I am saying my data 2
I'm extracting the year column and here
I am taking the consumption so let's
create a plot and here if you see we are
looking at a plot we do see some tick
times and we see that the data has been
divided with every two years so from
2006 onwards to 2016 but then really
this data does not give me uh you know a
very useful way of looking at the rate
or understanding it might be what I can
do is I can use the same way but I can
give apart from x axis and y axis I can
say that
limits that is X limit is 2006 to 2018
and Y limit is from 800 to 1700 so we
can do this and let's look at this again
this is a plot but it really does not
help me in visualizing and understanding
the data so what are the better options
I can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns so as of now we will
just keep it as it is par
MF row now
if I would want to plot I can straight
away give the column name so I am
interested in getting the consumption
now I can just do a plot I'll say my
data 2 and I will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here
from our data so consumption was the
second column so I can just do a plot in
a straight away way without mentioning
your x-axis y-axis limits and so on and
if you look at this this one is giving
me a pattern now here I am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph and
we are looking at the data it does show
me some kind of pattern but might be we
can make it more meaningful so I can do
it this way where I say my data second
column let's give access as ear x axis
y-axis is consumption now that has
changed the x-axis and y-axis now I can
also give some more details I can say
type should be line I have the line
width I'm saying color is blue and let's
do this so this looks more meaningful
maybe shows a wavering pattern of
consumption over years I can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying X limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018. I can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so I can do a
plot I can choose column second X lab
which is x-axis y-axis type is line
width giving X limit y limit and then
I'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph
and then basically you are looking at
the line graph now those are the options
which you can do either you could be
very specific or you could just give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details now what we can
do is if we would want to look at this
data and understand it better rather
than just looking at a simple line I can
take the log values so here I'm saying
log of my data to Second column so I'm
taking log values of consumption and I'm
taking the difference of logs so I can
say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it by some number so rest
Remains the Same I am changing the color
and let's look at this plot and you see
this basically is giving me a better
pattern which makes meaning here we see
the log values so this is you are using
a simple plot function
in R you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so I'll
say no I will access this by using the
library ggplot 2.
and now I can use ggplot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data 2 that's the data frame I am saying
type as o and when I'm saying line I am
basically going to use x axis which is
here Y is consumption and let's look at
this plot so again we are back to the
one which we were doing earlier really
does not make any sense gives us some
data but then really does not give me
enough information I can
in my Aesthetics I can say x as year Ys
consumption I can do a grouping and then
I can give line and plot so again we
have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so I'm just doing the same
thing here and I'm looking at line type
being test I'm using the GG plots other
methods such as geomline and geompoint
to give me more information and if I
look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but I would
still prefer the way we were doing with
plot now we can change the color and
obviously add details to it so what we
see is when you use the plot method
which I did earlier it was choosing
pretty good tick locations that is every
two years and labels the years for the
x-axis which was helpful right but with
these data points which we were seeing
here
or say for example this one
or say this one or say this one we are
looking at some data but then that
really is quite crowded and it is hard
to read you can look at the values but
then it really does not give you enough
information so we can go for plot method
but then we will see how we can consider
different data now if I would want to
plot the solar and wind time series so
let's see how do we do that
so wind column is what I'm interested in
so first thing is it is always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so I'm saying
minimum I am saying let's put in here my
data to
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns we know
consumption is the second column when
does the third column and you have solar
as the fourth and this one is the fifth
so let's say let's find out the minimum
of each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column and here I'm also
saying remove the any values because we
do not want to consider the any values
so let's let look at the minimum that
shows me
5.7757 what is the maximum value it is
826 so that also helps me in giving a
limit if I want to plot wind on y-axis I
can give a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or give some limits so that's fine now
for multiple plots as I said instead of
having one plot let's plot consumption
and wind and solar and try to see a
pattern so I can say par function and I
will say three rows and one column so
now when I start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier and let's
look at the data so that gives me some
data you can always do a zoom and you
can look at the data you can basically
expand this graph or you can reduce this
graph to see what kind of pattern we
have in consumption similarly we can
basically choose date being x-axis my
consumption being y-axis right so this
is being more specific because here we
have a range but it really does not give
me enough information so I will
basically give x-axis Y axis I will give
the name that is daily totals and then I
will basically give consumption color
and Y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this and now
we can look at the data here so let's
see this data makes a little more
meaning because we are looking at the
dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me how the data pattern is
changing for consumption now
this is for consumption so what we can
do is we can also extract specific data
so if you see here I have done some
testing where I am saying okay I would
want to get a date specifically
I would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just change the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it it would be good if we can convert
a column into date time format and put
that in our data frame now let's look at
the plot 2 this is mainly for your
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so here I see it is solar
data and I can plot this one to see how
it looks like
and that tells me from 2006 onwards we
have some pattern I can be more specific
where I say I would be giving date and
then
the column for solar x axis Y axis what
is the type what is the Y limit and what
is the color it is always good to
specify your X and Y axis give a name
rather than let it automatically pick up
now this makes more meaning because it
shows me some dates similarly we can do
for wind so either you do it just by
giving the column
or you give your X and Y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot 3 this one we can choose
plot 2 we can choose plot one and we can
put all that data in one graph so that's
when you are putting in multi plots in
one particular graph you can always do a
zoom you can always look at the data
right and this is usually useful to look
at the pattern what kind of pattern we
see what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window and let's basically plot
time series in a single year so what we
have seen is that when you look at the
plot method it was quite crowded then we
looked at solar and wind and if you
compare that you will see your
consumption pattern your solar pattern
your wind pattern and basically we can
see from this particular data some kind
of pattern so electricity consumption is
highest in the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in Winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year further into months we can see that
but we see a pattern which goes for
every year or every two years being
highest at a particular point of time
and then it drops down so electricity
consumption is highest in Winter and
that might be due to electrical Heating
and increased lighting usage and lowest
in summer now when you look at
electricity consumption appears to split
into two clusters we can always look at
the consumption one with oscillation
centered roundly around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at 1400 gigawatts
and you see all the values here which
are in that particular consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points centrally roughed around
1150 so if you really expand this you
can see you will have lot of data points
at this point
now we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production that is
highest in summer when sunlight is most
abundant and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you're
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge you are you know knowledge of
business to understand how this goes if
you look at wind power production that's
again highest in Winters and drops down
in summer so due to stronger winds and
more frequent storms and lowest in
summer
so there is some kind of increasing
Trend in wind power production over
years which we can see here
over the years
and all the time series data what we are
looking at is referring or showing us
some kind of seasonality that is we are
looking at seasonality in which a
pattern is repeating again and again at
regular times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons for example
if you look at retail stale sales data
uh that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months so seasonality when we say can
occur on other time scales so the plots
what we are seeing here they are fine
but if you look at those plots they
might show some kind of weekly
seasonality also so in your consumption
corresponding to weekdays and weekends
so let's plot for one single year now
how do I do that so first is I will look
at my data too
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is Factor other columns which
are all numerics now like we did earlier
I'll repeat this step where I'm going to
convert the date column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what I want to do is I want to add
this
and to my data frame so I will create a
variable called mod data and this one
will have as data and I'm formatting the
value of x which is date time into month
day and year so let's do that and now
you look at the mod data which I created
like modified data so this is the format
I have it is in date type if you
carefully see here and then I can look
at the head of it so it saves me mod
data now we are what we did here is when
I said my data 3
so my data 3 we did a c bind and I did a
mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data
too so my new data frame is my data 3.
let's look at the structure of it and
you see there is this date column I can
delete it I can remove it I can let it
be right so that depends on our choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular year now how do you do that
so this is some wrangling so I will say
my data 4 let's call it my data 4 and I
will use subset function so subset will
work on my data 3 that's the data and
what I'll do is I will do a subset how
does how is the subset found so I'll say
take the mod data column the value
should be greater than or equal to 2017
and should be less than
2017 December 31st so I'm getting data
for one year and I'm storing it as my
data 4.
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data now let's do a plotting of this
where I will only
create a plot for one year so I'm saying
my data 4 that's my new
data what we got
so
here I am going to take the first column
which is mod data
I am going to take the third column
which is consumption so I'm looking at
the date format for one year consumption
values for it and then rest of the
things as we have done earlier let's
look at the plot and this makes more
meaning right so when you look at this
plot it tells me Jan to Jan it shows me
some kind of pattern where I have
divided the year into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months Jan and March and May and July
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where I've broken it down into
months
so this is where you have taken time
series in a single year to investigate
further and this is what we see right
now we can clearly see there are some
weekly oscillations what one more
interesting feature is that at this
level of granularity that is when you're
looking at yearly data there is a
drastic decrease in electricity
consumption in early January and late
December during the holidays or probably
we can assume that this is holidays now
I can zoom in further and look at just
Jan and Feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data 3 I was doing a subset
and I was giving the date but this time
I will make it more narrower so I'll say
my data 4 I will say subset from my data
and I will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format I
will choose the starting date as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is Jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this now again as I said earlier
let's find out the minimum of this from
the First Column so that is basically
your mod data so let's look into this
one and that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the value so this one tells me
Jan 17 January 1 and maximum is
your
Feb 28th second month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I'm
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I am giving some naming
convention for sorry namings for your
x-axis y-axis what is my consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see I'm using X limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and Y limit so let's look at this data
and if you look at this data it is
specifically for two months and again I
can look at the pattern here what I can
also do is I can add some grid here
so I can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now I can add
a line here using AB line and then I can
basically choose what lines I would want
to add horizontally so that basically
allows me to dissect the data and look
at data in a more meaningful way I can
also add vertical lines so vertical
lines is I'm saying sequence will be
minimum maximum and I'm saying an
interval of seven so let's do this and
this basically has added some lines
every week and you can see at the end of
week it is dropping and then it is
starting again it Peaks somewhere in the
mid of the week and again it drops down
so this is you're looking at your
consumption data right now what we can
also do is we can create some box plots
so when we looked at zooming in data for
Jan and Feb you can add some data point
points like this so consumption is
highest on the weekdays as I showed you
here and lowest on the weekends so this
is what we are seeing when we are
breaking the data or zooming it further
for a couple of months so we have
vertical grid lines and we have nicely
formatted tick labels that is Jan first
and 15th Feb first and so on so we can
easily tell which days are weekdays and
weekends with use of these grid lines
and basically breaking it down so there
are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use histograms
and so on now moving further we would
want to explore the seasonality right so
when you further explore the seasonality
of our data we can use box plots
basically to group the data by different
time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so I can just do a simple box
plot and I can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
plot it is basically a visual display of
your Phi number summary that is you want
to look at your mean median you want to
look at your 25th percentile 50
percentile or 75th percentile so we can
use a quantile function use the
consumption column and then you
basically give a vector which shows you
Phi number summary so that's your
quantile and then let's do a box plot so
if you are looking at quantile it tells
me what is the minimum what is 25th
percentile 50 75th and 100 that's from
my consumption column so let's create a
box plot for consumption let's give it a
name as consumption let's give y-axis as
consumption and a limit for y-axis now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the year
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on year
so here I can give x axis y axis and I
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now I'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me 5 percentile or
sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot by just
giving consumption yearly grouped and
here I am giving the title as
consumption y-axis x axis and y limit
wherein I can also use less so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me the tick
points if you compare this one to the
previous graph so when I created this
previous graph I had 2 2006 2008 and I
had from 600 to 1800 and if I go for the
next one I am basically seeing more
useful information now let's look at
monthly data so I would want to group it
based on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where I'm looking at
months
and I could select a particular year or
I can just do a grouping based on months
so I can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this now
let's create a box plot for consumption
which is monthly data and let's give it
a color let's look at the wind data
which is again grouped monthly and let's
look at the solar data which is grouped
monthly now if I zoom in it basically
gives me the seasonality of the data for
your wind for your consumption for your
solar so what we are doing is we are
creating these box plots which are
giving us values now what I can also do
is I could look at the day wise also but
before we look into this how do I infer
some information from these box plots
which are being created so this is what
we have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me year seasonality which we were seeing
in earlier plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in Winters and
lower in summer so we can obviously look
at our plot we can see where it is lower
where it is higher and then we can look
at the median and lower two quartiles
are lower in December and January
compared to November and February so
that is you look at the quartiles and
you will see that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in December and January
here Jan and December so you can look it
from my plot now this is giving you some
idea on seasonality
now that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at your solar and wind
power production both will give you a
year seasonality what we are seeing here
and
if basically I look at the data so it
depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise so here let me again reset
this to one plot per graph now I'll say
box plot I'll say consumption which is
group based on day now we know that
there is a day column and let's give a y
limit and let's look at the data so this
is where I am grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here I have given day and I have chosen
all the 31 days but I can break it down
to a week and I can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption where I'm doing
a consumption group by day is higher on
weekdays than on weekends
so time series with strong seasonality
can often be represented with models
that can decompose signal into
seasonality and long Trend now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here we have
looked at data so what we will do is we
look at the frequency now when you look
at the frequency when you talk about
frequency in your data so we have the
modified date column which gives me a
frequency and if we really look into the
data that will tell me that the data is
on a daily basis so for that let's look
at my data 3 again which gives me data
and you can just see all the data's data
or dates are in sequence so your 22 23
24 25 26 and so on I can look at I can
access a d plier package
that is basically allowing me to work in
a better way now I can look at the
summary of this and for all my columns I
am seeing what is the minimum Phi number
summary date and consumption so date
does not show me anything because this
is not in a date format it is just a
factor but other things have the fine
number summary so we are looking at wind
solar we are looking at year and month
and day and all these columns now what
we will do is we will want to find out
the sum of each
column how many entries does it have and
we will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns so let me run this
again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have and these counts do
not include the N A values now similarly
I can find out specifically for
consumption I can find out is there any
n a value so I'm saying is Dot N A and
let's find out if there is any n a value
or missing value in consumption it says
0 okay that's good if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are n a
similarly solar similarly wind dot solar
or wind plus solar so it gives me a
count of n a values that is missing
values and also values which are not
missing so to understand frequency what
we can do is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the First Column and
I am saying RM
n a DOT RM is true that is get rid of n
a values and find out the minimum and
let's look at the minimum value this is
the minimum from my modified date
now if I would want to get the frequency
I can basically use sequence function so
I can say from X minimum that is the
minimum value I want to look at the
frequency that is day wise and let's
just look at five entries and see if
there is a day by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is daywise
frequency so that allows me to look at
the frequency look at the type of it it
is an integer class is a date so
similarly we can say from X minimum we
can basically look at the frequency
month wise and I can again look at five
records so that shows me monthly data
right so I can extract the data for
frequency similarly yearly data and
that's also very useful now we can
select data which has any values for
wind so how do I do it I would want to
find out the wind column and I want to
find out where the values are in a so I
will create a variable and here I will
say my data 3 and then I give a
conditional where I say is n a
in the column so let's do this now once
I have done this
once I have done this I have said that
my selected wind data from my data 3
where we said any values and I will give
the names to this so name should be in
my data 3 I am interested in mod data
consumption wind and solar so these are
the four columns I'm interested in let's
look at first 10 records here or first
10 rows so that tells me these are the
values where wind has n a or missing
values
I can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data so it basically shows
me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has any solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out any values
now what we will do is we will select
data which does not have any values so I
will call it cell selected wind 2
I'll again use my data 3 I will say
which but now I'm saying not any
from this column and I will select the
data for the columns so I am interested
in looking at 10 records and this shows
me not any value so no more missing
values so if I really look at this data
as I saw earlier which has n a and if I
look at these values which are not any
for the wind column so looking at these
two result we will know that in year
2011 wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do I
do that let's call it a different
variable I'll say my data 3 I will say
here when I say which where we were
saying n a here I will say the year
should have a value of 2011 and I want
all these columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
V
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame do a view and
this one will help me in finding out
where are the N A values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and I will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
I could select and search for one
specific value and I'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data and seeing is
wind column having n a or missing value
for a particular row and let's scroll
here and here you see there is a missing
value for one particular row so 13th
December 2011 has wind value 15 December
has wind value but your 14th December
does not have right similarly we can
search so there was only one entry which
was missing now that could be for some
reason might be it was not calculated
might be it was not tabulated so we have
a missing value and that can affect my
plotting that can affect my analysis so
let's look at the number of rows in this
which will tell me how many rows we have
for 2011 so it tells me 365 so that is
basically the number of days in a year
now we will find out if there were any
values so we earlier checked total
number of any values per column
that is in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269
so this is where we were seeing are
there any n a values right so let's go
back here
and
we want to find out the number of any
values for a particular year how do I do
it so I can just do a sum I will say is
n a now I am interested in my data 3
wind column and I am saying my ear has
to be 2011 but I am finding out the N A
values
so let's do this and it tells me 1 and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see how many non-na
values you have and that is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so it's 364 plus 1
missing so there are 365 let's look at
the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable
selected wind 4 I will say win 3 that is
which was having all my n a n non-na
values for 2011 I will say let's find
out the n a value
because I am interested in finding out
that particular row so I'm saying find
out where the value is n a and I want
all the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific
row which has a n a value
now we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has n a and
non-na values so let's say let's call it
test one I will use wind 3 which has n a
non-na values but now I will say I want
the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001 now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of December there is no date
so I will select a subset of data which
includes this n a and non n a that is
might be I can take 13th of December and
15th of December so let's start from 12
so the date should be greater than 12 12
that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have a I've selected a
subset of data I could have done this
using subset also so I have any and non
n a values now why are we doing this so
sometimes you might have some data for a
particular column and you may want to
find out if there are any missing values
might be you want to fill them up or
replace them with something so that is
usually useful when you are doing a
trend detection so say for example you
have data for every month and might be
in one one of the months you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly and then in one of the
years for a couple of months you don't
have the data like I can say 2016 I have
data for all 12 months 2017 all 12
months 2018 might be a don't have data
for March and June 2019 I don't have
data for same months so I can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous years same month data so we can
do that so here I have test data where I
have extracted a subset of data I can
look at the class of this it is a data
frame structure of this it has the
columns now let's use the library and
function and use the Tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so I will use test one I will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column wherein you
can take care of missing values forward
filled so filling values can be done in
different directions as I said and you
may want to First convert your time
series to specified frequency if your
data does not have a frequency but we
had now if you do not have a frequency
might be you can convert it into a
frequency such as weekly daily monthly
as I showed you and then basically you
can do a forward fill
for the values so for example if I have
my data I can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data I
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data then
let's look at the trends of the data
which is the last part of this project
so basically let's look at the trend So
when you say Trend what does that mean
so in Time series data you always have
some kind of trend so that will exhibit
some slow gradual variability in
addition to higher frequency variability
such as seasonality and noise now to
visualize these Trends what we do is we
use what we call as rolling means so we
know how our data is spread over year or
month or day but how about looking at a
rolling average and see what is the
difference so a rolling mean will tend
to smooth a Time series by averaging out
the variations and frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called those
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame you can also average out any
seasonality on a time scale equal to
window size so this will allow you to
look at lower frequency variation in the
data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean using the
zoo package and you can say what is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I am going to my look at my data 3 which
we have been using so far now let's call
it a three day test you can give it any
name I'm going to use my data 3 I'm
using the piping function
now I will use D plier and I will
arrange the data descending in here now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so I'll call it as
says 0 3 day so I'm going to calculate a
rolling mean every three days for my
consumption column and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and here
when I'm doing a three day test
let's look at the result of this and
then I'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven is
the average consumption in 2017 from the
first date with the data point on either
side of it that is you can look at this
date so one one three zero then you look
at
you are looking at the value one three
six seven here so you look at one one
three zero one four four one one five
three zero if I take a mean of these so
for example if I would just do this part
and that
is giving me mean okay because I have a
comment so let's basically add anything
as comment and then let's do this so it
saves me one three six seven that's what
we are seeing here right so you've got
getting a rolling average every three
days similarly if you want every five
days it takes the five values and it
gets the mid value right so you can
always find out the mean rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and E early data that is 365 days so how
do I do it same logic my data test
now I am using my data 3 I'm arranging
it in a descending order I am grouping
by year so when you do a group by year
so earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had right so
let's do a grouping by year and let's
say test zero seven so that's a rolling
average every seven days and I'm also
saying take care of the N A values
similarly I'm getting rolling average
every 365 days might be you can do
quarterly might be you can do half
yearly and let's do this so let's create
this my data test and let's look at the
result of this so I will use my data
test I will say arrange based on
modified date now we know there is a
column called modified date I want to
just look at 2017 data so I'm doing a
filter
right and then I will choose what are
the columns I'm interested in so I will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first seven records so let's do
this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average order of
seven day mean which is for first seven
days and then 365 you will not see the
data here but if I do a view on this I
can basically see the values so you can
always select a particular column to see
the values
these are the values for every seven day
rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days so you see all the values
are missing but every 365 entry you will
have basically some data
now let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting I will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is spread over a period of
time and that's fair enough but now
let's add some more plot to this so I
will add the seven day rolling average
to this so for second plot to be added
in the same one in R you can use points
so I will say points I will choose 7
data column type is line width X limit y
limit and color so let's do this and
that's my pattern seven day rolling
average which basically gives me some
kind of trend
similarly I can add one more here and
this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be aware in x axis and y-axis so I am
saying it will be 2500 and Y is 1800 so
my Legend will come in somewhere here I
am saying my Legend will have
consumption test and this one I can give
some names I can give what is the color
I can say what kind of
Legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
I've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here I see that my x-axis is fine but
y-axis is going a little about of my
plotting area so I can actually change
that so here I have 1800 how about
making it 1600 and let's look at this
one so we can basically uh go for this
one and start again here plot and points
and line and then add a legend right and
you can basically place your Legend
anywhere in the plot so this basically
is giving me the trend what I'm looking
at my rolling average so similarly you
can look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so seven day
rolling mean has smoothed out all week
leases anality which we were seeing Here
in My Graph where you look at every
seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality so seven day will tell that
electricity consumption is typically
higher in Winter and lower in summer so
better is you break it down uh yearly so
here if you look at every year you can
see when it's winter when it's summer
what is the seasonality what your Trend
what you are seeing here and if there is
a decrease or increase for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
365 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically
reduces the variation so if I look at
360 by Rolling mean we can see long-term
Trend in electricity consumption is
pretty flat now that's what we are
seeing it's kind of pretty flat there is
not much variation over years if you
really join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code
which you have here in the form of a
project.r file you can find here in my
GitHub page this is a document which
explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder so continue learning
and continue practicing r with that we
have come to the end of this full course
on our programming think we missed
anything important do let us know in the
comment section below thank you so much
for being here and do watch out for more
videos from us until then keep learning
and stay tuned to Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign